WE'RE GONNA WAIT A FEW MORE
MINUTES- FOR SOME COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO MAKE IT HERE ARE
SOME WON'T BE ABLE TO MAKE IT
BECAUSE THEY'RE IN DISTRICT-
BUT WE'RE WAITING FOR THE WORLD.
TWENTY FOUR MS CARILLO- MISTER
OFSHE KALRA EDUARDO GARCIA TOM
LACKEY KEVIN MCCARTY JAMES
RAMOS UNFORTUNATELY- RUBBER
READERS WILL BE ABLE TO MAKE IT
LOW REDNECK GONZALEZ WILL BE
ABLE TO MAKE IT AND DAVID CHIU.
IT WOULD GIVE A FEW MORE
MINUTES AND THEN WE'LL BEGIN
THE SELECT COMMITTEE. ON VOICE
A MINUTE COLOR.
THE DALLAS.
UHHUH UHHUH- OKAY GOVERNMENT
PANEL- DESPITE ALL FINDING.
NINE RIGHT. ALL RIGHT. SEARCH
LOOKING. FOR YEAH- REACH ME AT
OUT. TO YOU CAN. I'M HERE TO
BEGIN THE DISALLOW COMMITTEE
THE ASSEMBLY SO COMMITTEE BOYS
AND OF COLOR- BECAUSE WE HAVE
SO MANY. BEING THAT WE NEED TO-
BEFORE WE CAN BEGIN TO ARE GO
AHEAD AND THAT GIFT WRAPPERS
TIME- TO BE ABLE TO GET. UGH
WELCOME TO THE BEST SO
COMMITTEE HONEST OF BOY MEDICAL.
WE'RE PRESS PHYSICAL DISTANCING
HERE IN THE ROOM AND THROUGHOUT
THE CAPITOL BUILDING. M. WE
MINDFUL OF THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WE HAVE CONGREGATING IN THE
HEARING ROOM. WE'RE ALSO
REQUIRED IN MASS B. WORN IN
PHYSICAL DISTANCING BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL COMMITTEE
MEMBERS STAFF AND MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC. WEATHER HERE IN THE
ROOM OR AT A REMOTE. TESTIMONY
STATION IF YOU DO NOT HAVE A
MASK WE CAN PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU.
WE HAVE A FEW OPTIONS FOR
WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY. FOR
THE PUBLIC IN A ROOM TODAY IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- TO. WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE A MINIMAL
CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND A
LIMITED NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC.
AND MEDIA SO WE CAN MAINTAIN
SIX FEET SPACING. THEY'RE ALSO
STRICT PHYSICAL DISSENTING
PROTOCOLS IN MASS REQUIREMENTS
FOR THE PUBLIC- AND MEDIA AND
WE CAN MAINTAIN SIX FEET
SPACING THEY'RE ALSO STRICT
PHYSICAL DISTANCING PROTOCOLS
AND MASS REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE
CAPITAL IN THE DOES HERE. IN
THE ROOM. IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN A ROOM WOULD LIKE TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE
RAISE YOUR HAND IN THE ASSEMBLY
SERGEANT ARMS WILL DIRECT YOU
TO APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. WE HAVE
TO SPEAKERS DO NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE END OF YOUR
PUBLIC COMMENTS YOU MAY RETURN
TO YOUR SEAT ARE YOU MAY EXIT
THE HEARING ROOM. IF YOU'RE
TESTIFYING YOU MAY RETURN TO
HIS SEAT ARE YOU MAY EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM. PLEASE B SURE TO
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCING.
UPON LEAVING THE CAPITAL
INCLUDING LIMITING ELEVATOR USE
TO THE AMOUNT OF PEOPLE.
COMMITTED ON THE POSTING AT
EACH ELEVATOR. FOR DIALING
WITNESSES WEEK ALSO. WELL WE
ARE WE WILL ALSO BE USING THE
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE TO
WHICH ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
MAY PROVIDE COMMENT. DEAD
CALLING NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN
AGAIN THAT'S EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
ONE THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR TWO
ZERO TWO. AGAIN THAT'S ONE.
THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR. TWO ZERO
TWO. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY SELECT
COMMITTEE ON THE STATUS OF BOYS
HIM IN A COUPLE OF WEBSITE AS
WELL AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN. WILL
OPEN UP ONLINE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THE END OF THE FINAL
SPEAK TO THEM IN THE FINAL
SPEAKER. WILL THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO. BE
PLACED IN QUEUE TO SPEAK. IF
YOU'RE CALLING THEM PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE.
THIS INCLUDES BEATING. YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST IN YOUR
SMART TALK DEVICES TO REDUCE
THE SOUND DISTORTION. IF YOU'RE
HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN
TELL. THE COMMITTEE AT.
916-319-2059 AGAIN THAT'S
916-319-2059 AND MY STAFF WILL
BE THERE TO TRY TO HELP. I ALSO
WANT TO NOTE THAT WE WILL
ALWAYS ACCEPT WRITTEN COMMENT
FOR THE HEARING VIA EMAIL
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- DOT JONES
SAWYER AT ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT
GOV. THANK YOU FOR BEARING WITH
US AS WE IMPLEMENT METHODS TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE A
LOT OF CALIFORNIA WHILE ALSO
BEING MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF
THE PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE
ALL FACE. AND SO. WE HAVE TWO
HOURS NOW AND MAKE SURE WE
TAKE. WE USE EVERY MINUTE OF
IT. AND SO I WOULD LIKE TO
FIRST PANEL TO COME UP. OUR
PANEL NUMBER ONE POST PANDEMIC
APPROACHES FOR CURBING. GUN
VIOLENCE IN COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. I HAVE PANELISTS MICHAEL
MAKE LIVELY DIRECTOR OF
COMMUNITY VIOLENCE INITIATIVE
POLICY GIFFORDS LAW CENTER. AND
JULIUS DAVID- PROGRAM MANAGER
ADVANCE PEACE. AND SKIPPED TOWN
SAID FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR SECOND CALL AND PASTOR
MICHAEL MCBRIDE DIRECTOR OF
URBAN STRATEGIES I BELIEVE WITH.
WE'RE GOING TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO
COME UP HERE. SO ARE THEY ON
THE SCREEN. DEBORAH MOSTLY ALL
RIGHT TO SO TO BE FUN SO WE
HAVE MISTER- WE HAVE WANTED
MEMBERS HERE WOULD YOU DO YOU
WANT TO SAY ANY WORDS BEFORE WE
BEGIN OF THE SHARE LACKEY TOM
BLACK ASSEMBLY MEMBER. NO I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO- THE
INSTRUCTION THAT WE'RE GOING TO
GET TODAY- THIS IS A PART OF
OUR POPULATION THAT. DESERVES
THE ATTENTION AND A MUCH
STRONGER EFFORT DONE IS BEEN
DISPLAYED IN THE PAST. GREAT
AND AS EVERYONE KNOWS FROM.
THERE ARE PROBABLY TOO MANY
GUNS AND TOO MANY. PEOPLE'S
HANDS WHO SHOULD NEVER PROBABLY
EVER HAVE GUNNED DATA FROM THE
LOS ANGELES POLICE DEPARTMENT
SHOWED THAT PORN SIX FIVE
PEOPLE WERE SHOT IN THE CITY
BETWEEN JANUARY AND MAY OF THIS
YEAR- THAT IS A SIXTY SEVEN.
PERCENT INCREASE FROM THE SAME
TIME PERIOD LAST YEAR. THERE
WERE A HUNDRED FIFTEEN
HOMICIDES DURING A TIME WHICH
IS AN INCREASE OF 26% COMPARED
TO LAST YEAR AND SOME OF THE
DATA THAT'S COME OUT OF LOS
ANGELES. MANY OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WERE LATINO AND
AFRICAN AMERICAN AND SO IS IT
BEHOOVES US- THAT POST THIS
POST PANDEMIC. WE NEED TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT WE'RE DOING
WHAT WE NEED TO DO- AND SO WE
REALLY DO IF WE WANT TO PROTECT
OUR BOYS IN A COLOR. BOB THIS
YEAR WE NEED TO INFUSE STICK
CALIFORNIA VIOLENCE
INTERVENTION AND PREVENTION
GRANT PROGRAM. CALVET WITH A
LARGE SUM OF WE DID PUT IN
MONEY FOR A LARGE SUM TO FUND
THE WORK THAT WE SO DESPERATELY
NEED TO GET. NOW THE GUNS OFF
THE STREET BUT OUT OF THE HANDS
OF PEOPLE WHO SHOULD NOT HAVE
THEM- SO. WE MAY BEGIN WITH OUR
FIRST SPEAKER SO. I DON'T KNOW
HOW WE DO THAT. ELECTRONICALLY
PUT. GO FOR IT. I HAVE TO TRUST
SOMEONE ELSE. I BELIEVE IT'S
MAY HELP YOU CAN HEAR ME MISTER
CHAIR AND THIS IS MIKE MAKE
LIVELY AND IT'S ALL THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY AND THE
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I'M THE POLICY DIRECTOR OF THE
COMMUNITY BALLOT INITIATIVE
THAT CONFIRMS WHERE NATIONAL
GUN VIOLENCE PREVENTION
ORGANIZATION AND- BUT BASICALLY
IT'S PARTIALLY- CALIFORNIA BUT
WORKING IN THE STATE FOR MANY
YEARS. AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
HOMICIDES AND SHOOTINGS
AMERICA'S GUN VIOLENCE EPIDEMIC
HAS A DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT
AS YOU WERE SAYING ON YOUNG MEN
AND BOYS OF COLOR- BUT YOU
OFTEN ARE POLICY CONVERSATIONS
AND SOLUTIONS FAILED TO REFLECT
THAT. HERE IN CALIFORNIA 75% OF
HOMICIDE VICTIMS ARE BLACK IN
LATIN NEXT PEOPLE WITH MOST AS
YOU SPEND BEING MALE AND
HOMICIDE IS IN FACT THE LEADING
CAUSE OF DEATH FOR YOUNG BLACK
MEN IN CALIFORNIA AND ONE OF
THE LEADING CAUSES OF DEATH FOR
YOUNG LATINO MEN AND FOR EXTRA
CONTEXT NEARLY AS MANY
CALIFORNIANS LOST THEIR LIVES
JUST LAST YEAR. AS U. S.
SOLDIERS DEAD- DURING THE
ENTIRE CONFLICT IN AFGHANISTAN
OVER THE PAST TWO DECADES SO
COMMUNITY VIOLENCE IS AN
INCREDIBLY PRESSING DAILY ISSUE
INOUR STATE AND WE REALLY
THANK YOU FOR POSTING THIS
ANALYSTS TO DISCUSS SOLUTIONS
AND WHAT THE STATE CAN DO
BETTER TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
AS YOU SAID WE CAN'T TALK ABOUT
HOMICIDE IN BOUNCING CALIFORNIA
WITHOUT TALKING ABOUT GUNS
THREE QUARTERS OF HOMICIDES IN
THE STATE ARE COMMITTED WITH A
GUN AND CALIFORNIA IS A LEADER
WHEN IT COMES TO REGULATING
ACCESS TO GUNS AND GUN SAFETY
LAWS I'VE BEEN THERE A FEW
OTHER SOLUTIONS THAT WE CANNOT
IGNORE AT THE SAME TIME THE
FIRST IS BROADER AND INVOLVES
ADDRESSING THE SYSTEMIC
INEQUALITY THAT HAS LED TO
DISPROPORTIONATE LEVELS OF
POVERTY INCARCERATION AND
DIVESTMENT YOU MAYES OF COLOR.
AND THE SECOND MORE CONCRETE
GEN JUST AS IMPORTANT IS
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT
VIOLENCE IS BOTH A SYMPTOM AND
AT THE ROOT CAUSE OF MANY
QUALITY WE HAVE TO
INTENTIONALLY INVEST IN
COMMUNITY LED AN EVIDENCE BASED
PREVENTION AND INTERVENTION
STRATEGIES SO AS PART OF OUR.
WORKING GET RUNS WITH HELP
ORGANIZE A BROAD GOAL YOU KNOW
THE LAST FEW YEARS COMMUNITY
GROUPS ON THE GROUND. ACT I
FROM ACROSS THE STATE ALL I.
FOR TO MUCH. IN LOCAL. BASED
THE PILOTS THAT ARE FORMED BY
PUBLIC HEALTH PRINCIPLES AND
WITH YOUR HELP FOR WHICH WE ARE
VERY VERY GRATEFUL. I DO
MENTION THIS YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR'S THE
MINISTER WORK TO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR THREE YEAR
INVESTMENTS. IN CALVET THE
CALIFORNIA VIOLENCE
INTERVENTION AND PREVENTION
GRANT PROGRAM. AND THIS IS A
LOUD STRATEGIES LIKE ADVANCED
PIECE WHICH IS AN INTENSIVE
MENTORING PROGRAM FOR THOSE.
WHO ARE VERY HIGH RISK OF BEING
INVOLVED WITH SHOOTINGS- IT
ORIGINATED IN RICHMOND
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS SEEING
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTIONS IN
HOMICIDES AND SHOOTINGS IN
RECENT YEARS. AND WITH THE HELP
OF CALVET FUNDING THAT STRATEGY.
HAS BEEN SCALED. BACK YEAH AND
FRIENDS. I'M NOT. EVERY STUDY
FROM YOU BERKELEY HAS SHOWN
THAT THIS. HAS REDUCED. CITIES
AND PUBLICLY. SAVINGS FOR
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS AND IT'S
EXACTLY THE KIND OF LIFESAVING
WORK THEY COUNT THAT WAS
DESIGNED TO SUPPORT AND EXPAND.
I'LL CLOSE OUT MY COMMENTS BY
SAYING THAT THE INCREASED
INVESTMENT ACCOUNT THAT COULD
NOT COME AT A MORE CRITICAL
TIME. ALTHOUGH HOMICIDE REACHED
A SIX DECADE LOW HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND TWENTY NINETEEN.
WITH THE ONSET OF THE KOBE
PANDEMIC WE'VE SEEN LARGE
INCREASES IN COMMUNITY VIOLENCE
IN MAY CALIFORNIA C. AS WE
HAVEN'T CITIES ACROSS THE
NATION REGARDLESS OF THEIR
POLITICS. THIS BIG TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN
CALVET OVER THE NEXT THREE
YEARS IS HISTORIC BUT THERE'S
MUCH MORE THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE
IN TERMS OF SUSTAINING THE
PROGRAM OVER THE LONG TERM. AND
BUILDING A COMPREHENSIVE
SUPPORTER FOR ON THE GROUND
VIOLENCE INTERVENTION WORKERS.
WERE PUTTING THEMSELVES ON THE
LINE TO MAKE OUR COMMUNITY
SAFER SO WE ASK THAT YOU JOIN
WITH US AS YOU HAVE IN THE PAST
IN THE COMING YEAR. TO MAKE IT
COUNT WHEN A NATIONAL LEADER ON
THIS ISSUE. THE NEW TO SUPPORT
BONTA PREVENTION PREVENTION
WORK IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
AND- IF YOU COULD STND THE
LIGHT. AT ONE POINT I WANTED
TO- TO MAYBE HOLD OFF QUITE TO
THE BUT I JUST WANNA ASK. WE
CAN YOU STAY ON THE LINE. AND
IN. AT THE END WE CAN ASK
QUESTIONS AND USE ABOUT A TEN
FIFTEEN MINUTE SEGMENT. TASK
ALL THE PANELISTS DIFFERENT
QUESTIONS AND YOU MAY EVEN WANT
TO. ADD TO THE FREE IF YOU
COULD HANG AROUND. THAT WOULD
BE GOOD THANK YOU. NEXT WILL
HAVE A G. JULIUS THE VIDEO
PROGRAM MANAGER ADVANCE PEACE.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE HELLO
MY NAME IS JULIE IS TYPICAL ON
STRATEGY PROGRAM MANAGER FOR
ADVANCED YOU SACRAMENTO HERE.
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
WANTED TO ADDRESS. IS OF COURSE
ISN'T SUSTAINABILITY IN THESE
PROGRAMS. AND THE ABILITY TO BE
ACTUALLY TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THE
FREEDOM TO RUN THESE PROGRAMS
WHERE WE'RE NOT BEING TOLD BY
THOSE WHO ARE FUNDING THE
PROGRAMS HOW THOSE WHO DON'T
HAVE CULTURAL AWARENESS THOSE
WHO AREN'T. ALL MOVES ON THE
GROUND AND DON'T HAVE THESE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THESE YOUNG
MEN AND WOMEN WHO ARE WHO ARE
AT THE CENTER OF GUN VIOLENCE
IN WHO ARE AT HIGHEST RISK TO
EITHER BE PERPETRATORS OR
VICTIMS OF GUN VIOLENCE-
ADVANCE PEACE IS A PROVEN
STRATEGY THE PEACEMAKER
FELLOWSHIP. IS A PROVEN
STRATEGY THAT'S NOW BEING USED
AS MIKE STATED IN RICHMOND
SACRAMENTO. FRESNO AND STOCKING.
AND- COMING SOON TO VALLEJO.
AND OF COURSE IS THE NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION BUT OF COURSE
WE'RE HERE TO TALK ABOUT
CALIFORNIA- THE INCREASE IN THE
FUNDING ALLOWS US ROOT FOR IT
FOR INSTANCE A SITUATION LIKE
WE'RE FACING HEARING IN
SACRAMENTO- CAL PEOPLE ALLOWED
US TO HAVE A JUNIOR COLLEGE
YEAR- WHICH TARGETS INDIVIDUALS
AGES TWELVE TO SEVENTEEN NEVER
IN THE HISTORY OF US THE CITY
OF SACRAMENTO PRIOR TO THAT DID
THEY EVER HAVE ONE YEAR. WITH
NO JOB AND NOW I'M- THIS
FUNDING ALLOWED US TO ACTUALLY
WEIGH IN FOCUS AND BUILD
RELATIONSHIPS AND PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES TO THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO IT BASICALLY ALLOWED
US TO GO ON A TWENTY EIGHT
MONTH RUN. OF NO JUVENILE
HOMICIDES HISTORICAL RUN. AND
OF COURSE THAT WAS ENDED BY THE
PANDEMIC AND WHAT WE DON'T WANT
TO SEE IS. A DEEP THE DIET TO.
THE DISINVESTMENT BUT THEY'RE
WHERE WE'D NO LONGER WE NO
LONGER- FOCUSED ON INVESTING IN
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE FAR A WELL
THE OLDER GENERATION I THINK
WHAT ALLOW THIS. WOULD ALLOW US
TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN THIS AREA
IS THAT WE ALSO HAVE A SENIOR
FELLOWSHIP THAT ADDRESSES AND
FOCUSES ON INDIVIDUALS AGES
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY NINE AND
THESE ARE THE INDIVIDUALS THAT
PAGES. THAT THE AGES TWELVE TO
SEVENTEEN LOOK UP TO THE MALLS.
SO WHEN YOU'RE WHEN YOU'RE
BASICALLY HIT ME FROM ALL AREAS
AND YOUR PROVIDING
OPPORTUNITIES RESOURCES AND
BUILDING THESE RELATIONSHIPS
ARE WHAT YOU'LL HEAR FROM THE
CEO OF A BASKETBALL BOGEY. IS
THAT OCE YOU BUILD A
RELATIONSHIP WITH THESE YOUNG
MEN AND WOMEN THE SKY'S THE
LIMIT- WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
HEALING APPROACH WHERE WE ARE.
HIDING IN THE CAR. BEHAVIOR
THERAPY AND PRETTY MUCH GIVE
THEM ALTERNATIVES TO VIOLENCE-
ALTERNATIVE THAT THEY HAVEN'T
BEEN EXPOSED TO- AT AT A YOUNG
AGE WHERE NOW WHEN THEY AREN'T
WITH THEIR CREDIBLE MENTORS
WHEN WE CALL NEIGHBORHOOD
CHANGE AGENTS THEY'RE MAKING
BETTER DECISIONS- ULTIMATELY WE
BELIEVE THAT AT THE END OF THEDAY BECAUSE WE'RE NOT WITHIN
TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY. THAT
THIS IS THIS IS ULTIMATELY WHAT
WILL HAPPEN WHEN WE INVEST AND
WE SHOW THEM THAT SOMEONE
ACTUALLY CARES AND I KNOW I CAN
SPEAK AT LIVE ABOUT THE WALLS
IN THE DISTRUST AND THE
INABILITY TO POLICE OUR WAY OUT
OF THE SITUATION- IT'S REALLY
IT'S REALLY A HOLISTIC HEALING
PROCESS AND ANY SCRIPT- PROVEN
TO WORK. BUT WE HAVE TO LET THE
EXPERTS ON THE GROUND DO THEIR
JOB AND WE HAVE TO STEP BACK
AND ALLOW THEM TO BE SUCCESSFUL
IN AREAS WERE AGAIN OR I'VE
ALREADY STATED THAT RECRUITMENT
TO BE SUCCESSFUL SO I JUST
WANTED TO SAY THAT- ALSO WANT
TO END ON THIS NOTE THAT I
BELIEVE THAT WE WOULD DO A DO
CALIFORNIA GREAT SERVICE I KNOW
HERE SACRAMENTO WE HAVE THE
HIGHEST SUSPENSION RATE. AND ME
MYSELF COMING OUT THE YOUNG
PERSON WHENEVER I'M SUSPENDED
SIR I KNOW WHEN EVER ACTUALLY
WHAT WAS GOING ON. I WAS JUST
PUNCHED AND THREATENED WITH
MORE PUNISHMENT IF I CONTINUED
ON DOWN THIS PATH EVENTUALLY
EXPEL AND NOW WE HAVE THE SCOOP
PRISON PIPELINE BUT IF WE CAN
GET ANSWER OUR SALES IN THEIR
LIVES THAT THESE EIGHT AND
ACTUALLY MADE COGNITIVE
BEHAVIORAL THERAPY AVAILABLE
THINGS LIKE ANGER MANAGEMENT-
L. E. MOTIONAL CHALLENGED
AVAILABLE WEAPONS AT THE SCHOOL
LEVEL AT THE HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL
EVEN JUNIOR HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL.
I THINK WE CAN ALSO PUT A DENT
IN GUN VIOLENCE IN EVEN THE
EVEN THE DESIRE TO WANT TO HAVE
WITH YOUR WHICH WE KNOW WAS
BASED ON ACES AND TRIBE SO I
JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT I KNOW
WILL PROBABLY. CIRCLE BACK WITH
QUESTIONS LATER ON. THANK YOU
MISTER DAVIDO- I'M MORE NO MR
CAL IS ONLINE YEAH. MAY SO
LET'S GO TO PASTOR MICHAEL
MCBRIDE DIRECTOR OF URBAN
STRATEGIES FAITH IN ACTION.
INDIA WILL HAVE QUITE. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND GOOD AFTERNOON
IT'S GREAT TO BE WITH YOU WALL
AND- SO MUCH APPRECIATION. OUR
TO THE STATUS OF THE BOYS THE
MEN OF COLOR SELECT COMMITTEE-
WE I HAVE BEEN A PART OF. THOSE
COMMUNITIES- A SUPPORT SYSTEM
MEAN AND CHAMPION IS EFFORT
SINCE THE EARLY DAYS OF-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANDRA SWANSON
STAY CENTER SO THEY THIS IS
BRAND I EXECUTED AN IMPORTANT
PART. OF HOW WE HAVE LITERALLY
TURNED THE TIDE NOT JUST AT THE
STATE LEVEL BUT NATIONALLY WHEN
IT COMES TO WHAT CAN WE DO
STRATEGICALLY PRO DRESS- THE
LIVE CONDITIONS OF BOYS AND MEN
OF COLOR. IN OUR STATE I WILL
SAY THAT WE ARE NOW AT ANOTHER
CROSSROADS MOMENT. WE HAVE SEEN-
ONE OF THE LARGEST SPIKES AND
INCREASES OF GUN VIOLENCE- IN
ALMOST A COUPLE DECADES AND WE
HAVE I BELIEVE ONE OF THE
POLITICAL ARGUMENT AT LEAST
NATIONALLY AND HOPEFULLY
LOCALLY. THAT GUN VIOLENCE IS A
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE MEANING- WE
DO NOT HAVE TO RELY ON FAILED
STRATEGIES FROM THE NINETIES
ARE TOUGH ON CRIME APPROACH IS.
TO GET A HANDLE ON THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS THAT IS GUN
VIOLENCE INTERPERSONAL VIOLENCE
IN BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITIES
WHICH ARE A RESULT. OF COLD IT
NINETEEN- IMPACTS THAT HAVE
EXACERBATED THE ALREADY PRE
EXISTING CONDITIONS OF TRAUMA.
OF FEAR ANGER AND OF LOS IN OF
GRIEF WE KNOW. THAT IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA
PARTICULARLY BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES WE HAVE EXPERIENCED
SOME OF THE STEEPEST LOSSES
RELATED TO COVE IN NINETEEN. WE
ALSO KNOW THAT- THE MATRIARCHS
AND PATRIARCHS THE BIG MAMA'S
THE IRAQIS. CARE TAKERS THAT
HAVE LITERALLY KILLED SO MANY
OF OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS- HAVE
TRANSITION OR GOTTEN SICK TO
THE POINT DURING THIS CALL THE
NINETEEN THAT MANY OF OUR YOUNG
MEN AND BOYS ARE NOW LEFT
WITHOUT. A DEEP SOCIAL
STRUCTURE AND NET TO NURTURE
THEM TO PROTECT THEM AND TO
KEEP THEM SAFE. WHAT THIS
AFFORDS US IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
NOW BUILDING INFRASTRUCTURE
USING OUR TAX DOLLARS TO INSURE
THAT WE CAN SECURE SAFETY
HEALING. AND PEACE MAKING AT
THIS SCALE COMMENSURATE TO THE
CRISIS WE ARE FACING FACING. WE
DO HAVE A CONUNDRUM BEFORE US
THOUGH BECAUSE THERE IS A
TENDENCY IN THESE MOMENTS OF
VULNERABILITY PARTAKE WITH
BLACK AND BROWN YOUNG MEN THAT
WE REACH FOR A PUNITIVE
RESPONSE. RATHER THAN A HUMAN
RESPONSE. THE INFORMATION THAT
YOU HAVE HEARD. BY OUR.
PARTNERS ON THIS I'LL CALL IN A
AREN'T TESTIFY. GIVES US A REAL.
AND SH. AFTER WE'RE CAN LATER
CAPTURE THE YOUNG MEN AND BOYS-
WHO ARE CLAD IN VIOLENT CYCLES
OVER TIME AND ENSURE THAT WE DO
NOT LOSE THEIR LIVES OR THEIR
FREEDOM. AS WE ATTEMPT TO
SECURE PEACE AND SECURITY IN
OUR COMMUNITY. AND SO THE IDEA
THAT WE NOW HAVE. BECAUSE OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS SET ASIDE
BY THE GOVERNOR TO OUR
COLLECTIVE ADVOCACY AND WE ARE
LOOKING AT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND ARE ANTICIPATING
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS BEING PUT
INTO PLACE. FOR COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE THE HIGHEST RISK OF
SHOOTING. FOR BEING SHOT WE NOW
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY AT THIS
LEVEL IN THE SELECT COMMITTEES
NOT ONLY AFFIRMED THIS WORK BUT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS A
PLACEHOLDER FOR BUILDING AN
INFRASTRUCTURE OF PEACEMAKING
AND HEALING IN BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE. I
WANT TO SUBMIT TO YOU THAT WE
HAVE EXPERTS WHO COME FROM
THESE COMMUNITIES BROTHER
JUSTIN IS ONE HE'S ALREADY NAME
DROPPED HIS BOSS WHO MANY OF
YOU ARE VERY FAMILIAR WITH THE
PHONE BOCANEGRA MUHAMMAD.
REAGAN CUNNINGHAM SO MANY
OTHERS UP AND DOWN THE STATE'S
GIVE TOWNSEND ETCETERA ETCETERA
WHO CAN HELP US BE ABLE TO
ANCHOR THE STRATEGIES. IN THE
CITIES THAT ARE MOST IMPACTED I
WILL SAY TO YOU AS A FAITH
LEADER IS SOMEONE WHO IS- BEEN.
REALLY TRYING TO CHAMPION AT
CERTAINLY ACROSS THE STATE BUT
ALSO ACROSS THE COUNTRY A WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
LITERALLY REIMAGINE PUBLIC
SAFETY USING THESE STRATEGIES
AS THE TIP OF THE SPEAR. MY
HOPE IS THAT WE WILL NOT HAVE
TO CONVINCE ARE LIFTED
OFFICIALS IN THE MOST
PROGRESSIVE STATE TO REALLY GO
ALL IN ON THIS EFFORT. BUT THAT
WE CAN'T JUST LIKE WE WERE ABLE
TO SHIFT THE NATIONAL
CONVERSATION ON BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR TO THE SELECT COMMITTEE
WE CAN NOW HELP SHIFT THE
NATIONAL CONVERSATION TO
IMPLEMENTATION AND HOPEFULLY
FINDING AND SCALING IT
INFRASTRUCTURE. AROUND HOW WE
REIMAGINE PUBLIC SAFETY
PARTICULARLY AROUND GUN RELATED
SHOOTINGS AND HOMICIDES THAT
IMPACT BLACK AND BROWN MEAT IN
THEIR FAMILIES HOW CAN WE DO
THIS WITHOUT RETURNING TO
IMPUNITY OF APPROACH THAT GROWS
THE PRISON. THE JAILS AND THE
CRIMINALIZATION OF OUR
COMMUNITY. WE HAVE OUT
ACHIEVING THE PUBLIC SAFETY WE
SO DESIRE- WE HAVE A SIX IN OUR
AND- BUT WE ARE NOW EXT. A VERY
CHALLENGING EIGHTEEN MONTHS
SIMILAR PLACES LIKE FRESNO
SIMILAR PLACES LIVESTOCK IN
SIMILAR PLACES LIKE RICHMOND.
SIMILAR PLACES IN LOS ANGELES
AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WELL WE
CERTAINLY NEED TO SELECT
COMMITTEE TO HELP US MAINSTREAM
THIS WORK IN MANY OF US- OUR
ONLINE- WILL NOT JUST THE
BATTLEFIELD WERE ALSO STANDING
IN SOLIDARITY WITH YOU WANT TO
HELP MAKE THIS HAPPEN. ALSO
AGAIN DEEP APPRECIATION FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE GLAD TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS I DO BELIEVE
WE CAN BUILD A NEW POLITICAL
COALITION ABOUT PUBLIC SAFETY.
THAT DOES NOT OVER DETERMINAR
COMMUNITIES. AYE ACOSTA
POLICING OR PUNITIVE MISS-
THERE IS A WAY TO LITERALLY
FIND KEYS AND IT VANCE PLEASE
AND- CENTER HEALING AND MAY WE
MAKE IT SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER TOWNS ON YET OKAY SO
WE'LL GO TO QUESTIONS AND
ANSWERS AND I'LL- AND I'LL ALL
STARTED BECAUSE YOU IT EACH OF
THE PANELISTS GAVE SOME
IMPRESSIVE. I'M DATA AND
NUMBERS ARE YOUR SUCCESS RATE
USING- YOUR REHABILITATION
STRATEGIES- ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT NOW IN A PROGRESSIVE SIDE
BUT ALSO MY COLLEAGUES- FOR
EXAMPLE MR LACKEY NICER FROM
PUBLIC SAFETY. IS MY VICE CHAIR
AND ON. ON THAT COMMITTEE AND
WE ALSO SERVE. BONDI SUB FIVE
WHICH BY FUNDS ALL OF THE
PROGRAMS IN PUBLIC SAFETY ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT KIND OF
BRINGS BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE
TOGETHER. IS DATA. AND THEN
WHAT WE WHAT LIKE TO SEE IS
EITHER INTERNAL AUDITS. OR
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES TO SHOW
THAT YOUR NUMBERS ARE NOT ONLY
SUCCESSFUL BUT YOU'RE KEEPING
DATA OVER A PERIOD OF TIME
SHOWING YOUR SUCCESS RATE. AND
I AND I I'VE SEEN IT PERSONALLY
WERE EVEN INDIVIDUALS ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE AISLE WHEN
THEY SEE THE NUMBERS AND THEY
SEE HOW. IT IS A PROVEN ENTITY
THAT IT IT CAN WORK AND YOU CAN
SHOW THAT DATA. OF WE HAVE A
BETTER. SUCCESS RATE IN GETTING
FUNDING FOR ANY AND ALL OF
THESE PROGRAMS AND SO I KNOW
EACH OF YOU HAVE GIVEN SOME
SOME SOME SOME DATA. BUT I
WANNA KNOW INTERNALLY DO YOU DO
INTERNAL AUDITS DO YOU KEEP
RECORDS TO KEEP IT FOR FIVE
YEARS TEN YEARS. HOW DO YOU
MEASURE YOUR SUCCESS BECAUSE AT
THE END OF THE DAY FOR ALL OF
US ESPECIALLY POLICY MAKERS AND
PEOPLE HAVE TO MAKE DECISIONS
ON BUDGETS- WE WANT TO CONTINUE
TO GIVE MONEY TO THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS. AND I AND
I SEE MR LEKAN SHAKING HIS HEAD
HE HE TO WANT TO FUND- PROGRAMS
I KNOW MY COLLEAGUES. HERE MR
ASK CARO WHO'S JUST TRYING TO
SEE WHO'S CHAIRED PROGRESSIVE
CAUCUS ABU WE HAVE TO WE HAVE
TO SELL THAT TO EVERYONE TO ALL
EIGHTY MEMBERS AND THEN TO THE
SENATE AND INTO THE GOVERNOR
GOVERNOR. AND SO I KNOW IT'S A
LONG WINDED WAY BUT IF YOU
COULD GIVE US SOME EXAMPLES ON
ON HOW YOU CONSISTENTLY MEASURE
YOUR SUCCESS TO VALIDATE- WHY
YOU'RE SUCCESSFUL- IT WILL BE
GREAT FOR US AND WE CAN
INCORPORATE. SOME OF WHAT YOU
DO TO IT IN OUR AND OUR BUDGET
DELIBERATIONS WE COULD
INCORPORATE THAT AS A WAY TO
VALIDATE BECAUSE OF THE MORE
MORE WE CAN VALIDATE. THE MORE
MONEY I CAN GET YOU AND AS WE
ALL KNOW THE BEST WAY. TO STOP
A BULLET IS A JOB. IN THE BEST
WAY TO GET A JOB IS EDUCATION
AND THE BEST WAY TO GET A GOOD
EDUCATION TO CREATE ENVIRONMENT
SO YOU CAN GET BETTER EDUCATED
SO- I WILL. LEAVE YOU WITH THAT
IF THE ANY ANY ONE OF YOU- HAVE
ANY. SUGGESTIONS. OR IDEAS ON
HOW WE CAN DO THAT. YEAH I'M
GRANTED AT LEAST OFFER A COUPLE
OF REFERENCE POINTS FOR YOU
THAT CAN HELP QUANTIFY. THE
FISCAL IMPACT AND SAVINGS OF
THE SAID STRATEGIES. FOR THE
DATA MUHAMMAD WHO HAS BEEN A
KEY ARCHITECT OF THIS WORK FOR
MANY YEARS- HE'S BEEN HELPING
LITERALLY TO BE ONE OF OUR A
BILL STATE AND NATIONAL
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE EXPERTS TO
THE- NATIONAL INSTITUTE FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM. A
GROUP THAT PRESIDENT MUHAMMAD
BOTH MYSELF AND OTHERS I HELPED
A LOT SEVERAL YEARS AGO HAS A
WHOLE WEBSITE OF REPORTS. THAT
CAN HELP QUANTIFY WHAT WE CALL
THE COST OF VIOLENCE- THE KIND
OF COSTS THAT ARE. LITERACY
ACCUMULATED BY EVERY SHOOTING
THAT HAPPENS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES- THE COST OF
AMBULANCE TO COST OF- HELD
SERVICES CRIMINAL JUSTICE.
SYSTEMS THE CITY COUNTY AND
STATE COSTS FOR GUN VIOLENCE
PER SHOOTING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- COST THE STATE ONE
POINT SEVEN NINE MILLION
DOLLARS PER SHOOTING. ACCORDING
THESE CALCULATIONS AND AGAIN
YOU CAN GO TO ACOSTA VIOLENCE
DOT ORG AND JUST SEE- THESE
VERY IMPRESSIVE- WELL- PRODUCED
AND EVALUATED- KIND OF NUMBERS.
ONE OF THE MOST. POWERFUL
COMPONENTS SO HOW WE HAVE DONE
OUR WORK IS TO ARTICULATE OR
DEFINE THE COST FOR PEACE. AND
SO WHAT WE HAVE FOUND. IS THAT
IT LITERALLY. ALL ABOUT FOR TO
DOLLARS. PER PERSON- THAT IS.
YOU KNOW RESOURCES DEDICATED TO
SOME KIND OF LIVABLE WAGE FOR A
JOB- FULL TIME CASE MANAGER-
AND SOME OTHER SELECTED
SERVICES- IF YOU TAKE THE- THE
CUMULATIVE NUMBER OF. THAT
INVESTMENT IN ONE PERSON- THAT
LITERALLY WILL SAVE YOU
MILLIONS OF DOCTORS OVER TIME-
IN THE FIRST YEAR IN THE CITY
OF LOCAL WE HAD ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS WHO WE
IDENTIFIED WERE AT THE HIGH
SCHOOL SCHOOL SHOOTING OR BEING
SHOT. AND WE ESTIMATED THAT
THAT- EXPENSE TO THE TAXPAYERS
IT OPEN WAS ABOUT THIRTY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS. OVER SEVERAL
YEARS OUR INVESTMENT USING
THESE KINDS OF NUMBERS AND
METRICS LITERALLY- YOU KNOW
REQUIRED AN INVESTMENT OF ABOUT
TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS. OVER
THOSE FOR FIVE YEARS WE WERE
ABLE TO SEE A REDUCTION BY 50%
IN THE GUN RELATED SHOOTINGS OR
HOMICIDES IN THE CITY OF OAK. A
CITY THAT WAS LITERALLY
SPENDING OVER FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR- JUST IN
COLLATERAL COSTS WITH OUR
STRATEGIC INVESTMENT OF ABOUT
TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS PRODUCED
A 50% REDUCTION. THESE ARE NOT
ANECDOTAL NUMBERS BUT THESE ARE
NUMBERS THAT CAN BE PROVEN.
WITH- EVALUATIONS. WITH
RESEARCH AND CERTAINLY WITH-
OUR I THINK THE BUDGETARY
IMPLICATIONS THAT YOU ARE RIGHT
MEET- LIFTING UP FOR BOTH ARE A
DEMOCRAT REPUBLICAN AND
INDEPENDENT LAWMAKERS AT THE
STATE LEGISLATURE SO WE ARE
VERY EXCITED. AND WILLING TO
OFFER- THESE KIND OF THE-
TALKING POINTS ARGUMENTS AND
STUDY SO YOU WALKING NUMBER
QUESTION YOURSELVES- NOW OF
COURSE I WOULD JUST SAY AS A
PASTOR TO FAITH LEADER- HOW
MUCH. IS A LIFE WORDS AND I
WOULD SAY TO YOU- THESE NUMBERS
PALE IN COMPARISON TO THE KIND
OF LIVES THAT WE ARE LITERALLY
KEEPING ALIVE AND FREE TO
STABILIZE NEIGHBORHOODS
COMMUNITIES AND FAMILIES. AND
SO THE PRICELESS NATURE OF A
LIFE- CERTAINLY IS OUR VALUES
THAT DRIVES. TO WORK THE FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITY THAT'S BEING
ASKED OF US WE WERE. TALKING
ABOUT THE USE OF TAXPAYER
DOLLARS. THANK YOU TO READING
COMES FOR IN A OTHER. I WOULD
JUST BRIEFLY ADD ON IN THAT
THAT THEY COUNTED COALITION HAS
BEEN REALLY FOCUSED ON THIS
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS AND I'M
EXCITED TO SEE WHAT'S GOING TO
COME FROM ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
BEING ALLOCATED TO COMBAT PART
OF THE. SB SEC WHICH
ADMINISTERS COMMENT THE ABILITY
NOW TO CONTRACT WITH A THIRD
PARTY RESEARCHERS ARE GETTING
DATA COLLECTION AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND EVALUATION OF
THE IMPACT OF THE PROGRAM FOR
THE FIRST TIME WE HAVE NOT HAD
THE ABILITY TO DO THAT BEFORE
BECAUSE OF LACK OF RESOURCES
SO. THAT'S GONNA LET US SEE
MORE DATA THAN WE'VE EVER SEEN
BEFORE HOW ABOUT GROUPS THAT
ARE DOING THE WORK TO COLLECT
DATA AND MORE EFFICIENT WAY AND
I WOULD OUR WEEK I MEAN WE
ALREADY HAVE VERY IMPRESSIVE
RESULTS THAT ARE OUT THERE BUT
THIS IS GOING TO FURTHER CEMENT
THAT- JUST AS AN EXAMPLE THE UC
BERKELEY STUDY I MENTIONED
LOOKING AT ADVANCE PEACE IN
SACRAMENTO. SITE TWENTY TWO AND
39% DECREASES IN HOMICIDE- OVER
THE PRIOR ONE OR TWO YEAR
PERIOD IN THE NEIGHBORHOODS
WHERE ADVANCED PIECES BEEN
ACTIVE NINE DOUBLE DIGIT
REDUCTIONS IN MANY DIFFERENT
CITIES WE LOOK AT A DIFFERENT-
AND THE WHOLE STATE AND SONIC
CALVET FUNDED CITIES SOME
REDUCTIONS IN OVERALL HOMICIDES
THREE TIMES FASTER OR THREE
TIMES GREATER I SHOULD SAY THAN
NON CALVET FUNDED CITIES SO. WE
CAN SEE THAT THE PROGRAM AS A
WHOLE IT MAKE AN IMPACT AND I
THINK WITH THE NEW- THIRD PARTY
RESEARCH CONTRACT AND DEEPER
ABILITY TO DO EVALUATIONS WILL
HAVE EVEN MORE- VERY GRANULAR
IMPACT INFORMATION AVAILABLE SO
WE'RE EXCITED ABOUT THAT WELL I
PASTOR MIGHT BE PASSED REGARD
WITH THING- THERE'S ALREADY A
VERY COMPELLING CASE TO BE MADE
POSSIBLE ANNOUNCES EXTREME. AND
THERE'S VERY SPECIFIC STUDIES
ON THE COST SAVINGS- AND THE
LIVES THAT ARE BEING STATE I'M
IN CITIES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
THAT ARE BEING SUPPORTED BY.
THANK YOU. MISTER CAR HAS A
QUESTION. THANK THANK YOU- AND
I REALLY APPRECIATE PEOPLE TO
THE TIME OF AND CREDIBLE THE
SPEAKER AND ALL THREE PANELS SO
HAPPY TO BE HERE AND TO LEARN
AND TO LISTEN AS WELL AS OFFER
SOME THOUGHTS. AND WHAT ONE OF
THE THINGS I CAME UP WITH ALL
THE FOLKS IS SPOKEN AND I THINK
THAT WE KNOW THAT HAVE SEEN
SUCCESS IN SOME OF THESE
PROGRAM APPROVAL CONCEPT IS
THERE BUT OF COURSE THE NEXT
QUESTION IS HOW MUCH THE COST
WAS GOING TO PAY FOR IT. AND SO
IT IN IN MY HOME TOWN IN SAN
JOSE- WE'VE BEEN TAKING A
LITTLE BIT MORE OF AN
AGGRESSIVE STANCE ON THAT AS OF
LATE. ON A COUPLE FRONTS
BECAUSE IN THE CITY IS SOUNDS A
ALONE. IT'S ESTIMATED THE COST
OF. GUN VIOLENCE APPROXIMATELY
AS A PROXY FOUR HUNDRED FORTY
TWO MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR. A
THIRTY FIVE MILLION OF WHICH IS
DIRECT. OUT OF POCKET COST.
SEVENTY EIGHT MILLION OR SO.
LOST WORK. AND THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY EIGHT MILLION IN QUALITY
OF LIFE. SO ULTIMATELY WHO
SHOULD PAY FOR THAT NOW WHO
WILL WHO WERE SHOULD NOT BURDEN
WHY. HE SHOULD BE ON EVERY
WONDERFUL TO BE SOME SENSE OF
RESPONSIBILITY. ON THOSE THAT-
HAVE GUNS AND EVEN IF THE
RESPONSE OWNERS I. HAVE AUTO
INSURANCE. AND MANY RESPONSIBLE
DRIVER THEY DON'T GET A TICKET
FIFTY YEARS. THEY PAY INTO THE
INSURANCE SYSTEM RIGHT. BECAUSE
AN ACCIDENT CAN HAPPEN EVEN IF
YOU'RE A GOOD DRIVER- AND SO.
ONE OF THE CONCEPTS BROUGHT
BOARD OVER THERE WAS ACTUALLY
APPROVED BY OUR CITY COUNCIL
WAS. OF IT IN TERMS OF REDUCING
GUN HARM THROUGH AN INSURANCE
MANDATE IS REQUIRING. OWNERS TO
CARRY LIABILITY INSURANCE. ON
THE OTHER- REGARDING REDUCING
THE PUBLIC COSTA GUN VIOLENCE.
IS HAVING A FIFTY- TO COVER TAX
PER COSTS FOR EVERYONE THAT
POSSESSES OR OWNS A GUN- IN OUR
CITY. AND SO THAT'S OF THOSE
ARE A COUPLE BEHIND AND
THOUSANDS MORE THAN I WAS THE
FIRST CITY TO DO THAT- TO IS TO
HAVE BOTH THE INSURANCE MANDATE
AND THAT IS IN ADDITION. HAVE A
FEE. FOR OPEN GUN OWNERS AS ARE
ANY OF THE PANELISTS OF YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THAT BECAUSE AGAIN
I WANT THE PROGRAMS THAT YOU'RE
RUNNING NEED TO BE FUNDED BY
SOMEONE AND SOMEHOW. AND I
THINK THAT THERE IS. WE'VE
SHOWN WITH AUTO INSURANCE THAT
THE ABILITY TO USE RISK
ADJUSTED PREMIUMS TO REWARD
GOOD DRIVING. AND INCENTIVIZE
USE OF SAFETY FEATURES AIRBAGS
WHAT HAVE YOU SOME ONLY YOU CAN
REWARD TAKING SAFETY CLASSES
USING GUNS SAVES A STALLING
TRIPPING ON AND ON AND ON COULD
BE REWARDED. BY AN INSURANCE
CARRIER SOMEONE OPTS NOT TO DO
IT MAYBE THE PRIOR INSURANCE
BUT JUST THROWING THAT CONCEPT
OUT THERE TO SEE TO HELP FUND
SOME OF THE GREAT WORK THAT YOU
ALL ARE DOING AND OTHER. TYPES
OF PROGRAMS AND NEEDS. AS WE'RE
GONNA BE DISCUSSING THE REST
THIS AFTERNOON. GRADUATES NO I
JUST I JUST WAS GOING TO SAY
BEFORE YOU SPEAK MY- THAT WE
HAD WE HAD SUGGESTED THAT A GUN
TAX. BE PLACED ON ON GUN SALES
AND THAT THAT MONEY WOULD BE GO
THAT MONEY WOULD BE A- GOOD FOR
CHECKOUT. SO I KNOW MY CAN.
EDUCATE YOU MORE SO ON THAT
BECAUSE IT RAN INTO SOME
HURDLES. SOMEWHERE ALONG THE
LINE AND LEGISLATION. BUT I
ALSO WANTED TO ADD REAL QUICKLY
THAT- ALSO WITH THE WITH THE
WITH THE ABILITY TO TRACK. COST
SAVING. WE ALSO CONTRACT.
CONTRACT HOW WILL INDIVIDUALS
PERFORM- YOU CAN LOOK AT YOU
CAN ALSO GO TO THE ADVANCED
THESE WEBSITES IN ALL THE
ADVANCED HE CITIES NEAR IN
CALIFORNIA. WE'RE UC BERKELEY
PROVIDES- AN ASSESSMENT A ONE
YEAR ASSESSMENT IN A TWO YEAR
ASSESSMENT OF EACH PROGRAM. AND
IT'LL IT'LL GIVE YOU DETAILS ON
HOW YOUNG PERSONS DOING WHETHER
OR NOT THEY HAVE A LIFE MAP
WHETHER OR NOT THEY HAVE PLEASE
CONTACT WHETHER OR NOT THEY GET
INVOLVED. WITH FIREARMS WHETHER
BEING ARRESTED OR BEING A
VICTIM OF FIREARM ASSAULT
DURING THE TIME THAT THERE IN
EIGHTEEN MONTH COHORT SO I JUST
WANTED TO ADD THAT IS REALLY
EXTENSIVE- REAL PROFESSIONAL
AND REAL INFORMATIVE. WELL MY
CAMERA CAN BETTER ANSWER THAT
QUESTION IN REGARDS TO HOW WE
GET BETTER FUNDING. THANK YOU.
THANKS TO IT I WOULD JUST
QUICKLY YOU KNOW ARE THE CAP
THE COALITION I MENTIONED CAL
THE COALITION IT REALLY
CAREFULLY LOOKING AT THIS FOR
NEXT YEAR NOW AS THINGS STAND
RIGHT NOW. WE'RE DEPENDENT ON
YOU KNOW FUNDING HELP OF THE
GENERAL FUND WHICH MEANS WE'RE
COMING BACK AND FIGHTING FOR
FUNDING EVERY SINGLE YEAR AND
IT'S GONNA BE VERY IMPORTANT TO
JUST IN BAD THIS SYSTEM INTO
CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR. AND WE'RE
LOOKING AT CREATIVE WAYS TO DO
THAT I THINK RIGHT NOW THERE'S
ALL KINDS OF OPPORTUNITY- FROM.
WHETHER IT'S BREEDING AND
FEDERAL FUNDING FROM THE
AMERICAN RELIEF PLAN OVERSEEING
STATES DOING CROSS THE COUNTRY
I WE'RE SEEING JUST THIS YEAR
CONNECTICUT AND ILLINOIS FOR
THE FIRST TIME. ARE HARNESSING
MEDICAID TO USE A 50% FEDERAL
MATCH TO REIMBURSE VIOLENCE
PREVENTION PROFESSIONALS ARE
DOING THE WORK- AND THEN I
WOULD SAY WE'RE LOOKING VERY
CLOSELY. AT THE POSSIBILITY OF
SOME SORT OF EXCITED SPEED OR
TAX- RELATED KIT TO AMMUNITION
AND FIREARMS SALES WHICH ARE I
SHOULD MENTION I HAVE RECORD
LEVELS IN TWENTY TWENTY LAST
YEAR AND IN IN CONJUNCTION
COULD RECITE HUGE SPIKE. NOT
JUST IN VIOLENCE BUT IN GUN.
SALES AS WELL WHICH I DON'T
THINK IT'S A QUEEN EVENTS. AND
IT'S TIME WHEN THERE ARE. NO
RECORDS. FOR THE GUN INDUSTRY
AT THE TIME WE BE CAP. SOME
THAT AND- AFTER THE NAKED NEXT.
OF FIRE AND EVEN ARE CAN. AND
AN USING TO AND BACK INTO THE-
ARE BEING MOST THIS. IMPACTED
BY THOSE LEFT IN. AND LASTING
AFFAIRS ROUGH LOOKING AT THE
CURSOR. BILLS TO CREATE COST
SAVINGS- SIMILAR PROP FORTY
SEVEN AND OTHER GOING ON
JUSTICE REFORMS- AND THESE ARE.
I'M DOUBLE BENEFIT AND THAT THE
ADDRESS THAT MAJOR
INCARCERATION PROBLEM THAT WE
HAVE IN CALIFORNIA AND IN THE
UNITED STATES IN GENERAL AND
THEN TAKE THOSE SAVINGS AND
REINVEST THEM BACK INTO
COMMUNITIES AND ALL STATE.
BEING FROM A GROUP THAT DOES
WORK ON FIREARM POLICY GUNS AND
FIREARM LAWS ARE ONE OF THE
AREAS WHERE. UNITED THAT HAVE
MAJOR NEGATIVE IMPACT ON
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND AS A
STATE WE HAVE TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT AND CAREFUL WAY. AND SCALE
BACK ON EXPENSE WHERE IT'S
APPROPRIATE AND USE THOSE COST
SAVINGS TO BUILD COMMUNITIES
BACK UP RATHER THAN. TEARING
THEM DOWN WITH UNITIVE
APPROACHES SO WE'RE LOOKING AT
ALL OPTIONS AND REALLY. WANT TO
ESTABLISH SUSTAINABILITY- IN
THE IN THE COMING LEGISLATIVE
SESSION I LOVE THE COKE OF THE-
THE NEED TO QUANTIFY IS
ABSOLUTELY THERE TO BE ABLE TO
SHOWCASE. THAT CONNECTING THE
DOTS BETWEEN THE COST SAVINGS
OF THE OF THE CARCERAL SYSTEM.
AND GOING INTO PROGRAMS THAT DO
WORK AND TOO MUCH OF THE BILL'S
POINT. OF WE HAVE THE DATA WE
CAN SHOW WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH
THE MONEY ITS ACCOUNTABILITY.
IT'S WORKING. AND I THINK
ULTIMATELY- IF YOU DON'T HAVE
ONGOING FUNDING YOU DON'T HAVE
FUNDING. AND SO FINDING WAYS TO
GET ONGOING FUNDING BECAUSE YES
WE MIGHT BE IN A GOOD ECONOMIC
TIMES TODAY. WE GO INTO
RECESSION NEXT YOU KNOW THOSE
PROGRAMS ARE GONE YOU HAVE TO
JUST NOT SUSTAINED OVER MANY
YEARS. THEN YOU HAVE TO REBUILD
IT EVERYFEW YEARS AND THAT
DOESN'T WORK ESPECIALLY WITH
OUR YOUTH THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THE MAJORITY BY MISS CAREER DID
YOU. HAVE A QUESTION FOR YOU ON
THIS PANEL. OKAY SO I WANT TO
THANK EACH OUR PANEL. THIS DISS
VERY VERY GOOD IN A LIGHT. AND
WE GOING TO TAKE TO DATA. AND
MOVE FORWARD WITH IT AD-
DEFINITELY GET BACK TO YOU SEE
THAT WE CAN. FOR NOW YEAR. TO
GIVE THANK YOU PANEL NUMBER
ONE. THE NOW WILL BRING ON.
CHANNEL TWO- MITIGATING DEPEND
DEMOCRATS NEGATIVE IMPACT ON
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. AMONG
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR- I HAVE
SEVERAL PEOPLE LEANDER CLARK
HARVEY PHD CHIEF EXECUTIVE.
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL COMMUNITY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCIES.
SHE'S HERE. ANDREA CHAPMAN. MA
FOUNDER AND CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OFFICER UNITY CARE. HE
I BELIEVE HE'S HERE JOSEPHINA
ARADO MADE MAYNA- CHIEF EXEC
ROCKER SAFE PASSAGES- JACK
BARBER MD PRESIDENT AND CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND
REHABILITATION PROGRAM. AND YOU
TACOS BRINGER PHD DIRECTOR OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. NATIVE
AMERICAN HEALTH CENTER
GATHERING OF NATIVE AMERICANS
GONNA- EGYPT FIVE MINUTES
APIECE AND YOU WANT TO START
WITH DOCTOR HARVEY. YES THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WTH YOU
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH FOR BOYS AND
MEN OF COLOR DURING BOTH THE
HEALTH AND THE RACIAL PANDEMIC
THAT WERE ALSO COPING WITH I
WANT ESPECIALLY CHECK THINK THE
CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE FOR HIS
COMPREHENSIVE AND THOUGHTFUL
AGENDA INCLUDING A PANEL ABOUT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. AND THANK
YOU TO HIS STAFF FOR
FACILITATING OUR PARTICIPATION
TODAY SO I'M JUST GONNA TO
SPEAK BRIEFLY BECAUSE THE STARS
ARE REALLY NEXT TO ME BUT I
WANT TO GROUND THE DISCUSSION
TODAY HISTORICALLY BLACK
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE OF COLOR BY
POP COMMUNITIES. THEIR USE OF
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER SERVICE HAS BEEN
IMPACTED BY SEVERAL FACTORS
INCLUDING ACCESS TO TREATMENT.
CULTURAL BELIEFS AND STIGMA.
AND BECAUSE OF THIS ONE BY PARK
INDIVIDUALS DO SEEK HELP IT
TENDS TO BE AT A TIME OF
CRISIS. AT AN EMERGENCY ROOM A
PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITAL OR DUE TO
SOME TYPE OF- INTERACTION WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT. AND WE'VE ALSO
SEEN THAT SINCE THE START OF
THIS PANDEMIC. YOUTH AND IN
PARTICULAR BY PARK YOU HAVE
EXPERIENCED A 10% INCREASE IN
OPIOID USE WE'VE SEEN INCREASES
IN YOUTH DEATH BY SUICIDE.
CALLS TO CRISIS HOTLINE HAVE
INCREASED FOR EXAMPLE THE
NATIONAL SUICIDE PREVENTION
LIFELINE THAT SEVERAL OF OUR
MEMBERS RUN HAVE SEEN THIS
INFLUX AS WELL. AND IN A
NATIONAL COUNCIL FOR MENTAL
WELLBEING STUDY OF FOUR
THOUSAND BIPAP ADULTS DURING
THE KOPET NINETEEN PANDEMIC
THEY FOUND THAT 11% OF BLACK
ADULTS THEY QUOTE FINDING AN
ORGANIZATION THAT LOOKS LIKE
ME. OR SHARES MY CULTURE AND
IDENTITY HAS BEEN THE LARGEST
OBSTACLE TO SEEKING TREATMENT
FOR THEIR MENTAL HEALTH. NOW
WE'VE SEEN A RISE IN DEPRESSION
AND ANXIETY THAT HAVE BEEN
DIRECTLY LINKED TO HOW THIS
RACIAL PANDEMIC HAS REALLY
REARED ITS UGLY HEAD AND
IMPACTED MANY COMMUNITIES. SO
ALL OF THIS IS PROBLEMATIC AND
WE ANTICIPATE THAT OUR STATE
WILL SEE AN INFLUX OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH EMERGENCIES
AS CHILDREN GO BACK TO SCHOOL
AND PARENTS GO BACK TO IN
PERSON WORK. SO THERE'S A LOT
THAT NEEDS TO BE PROCESSED AND
THERE NEED TO BE SUPPORTS IN
THE COMMUNITY AND PLACE TO HELP
BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES COPE IN THE
AFTERMATH OF THESE PANDEMICS.
SO DESPITE THAT VERY BLEAK
PICTURE THAT I PAINTED I THINK
THE MOST IMPACTFUL PART OF THIS
PANEL IS THE MEMBER AGENCIES
THAT C. B. H. A. RPRESENTS
THAT PROVIDE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES TO OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
ANNUALLY. SO WE HAVE TO
REMEMBER AGENCIES AND OUR
COLLEAGUES FROM THE NATIVE
AMERICAN HEALTH CENTER HAVE
ALSO JOINED US HERE TODAY. AND
THEY'RE GOING TO FOCUS ON THE
POSITIVE PROGRAMS AND THE
INTERVENTIONS THAT ARE BEING
FACILITATED ACROSS COMMUNITIES
IN CALIFORNIA. OUR GOAL IS
SIMPLE TODAY IT'S REALLY TO
PROMOTE AN UP LEFT CULTURALLY
SPECIFIC MODELS THAT TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THE UNIQUE HISTORICAL
TRAUMA AND MOST IMPORTANTLY THE
RESILIENCE OF BOYS MEN OF COLOR
THEIR FAMILIES. AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES SO THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY I WILL SEE
MY TIME TO OUR FIRST WITNESS
UNDER CHAPMAN BEFORE YOU BEGIN
MISTER. SUTTON DR HARVEY COULD
YOU GET A LOT OF PEOPLE OUT
THERE LISTENING NO WOULD BY
TALK MEANS SO COULD YOU BREAK
THOSE LETTERS OUT FOR. SURE
AGAIN BLACK INDIGENOUS PEOPLE
OF COLOR BYE. THANK YOU. A GOOD
AFTERNOON SPEAKER- THANK YOU
FOR UP TO YOUR SPEAKING AND
OBVIOUSLY I SEE MY GOOD FRIEND-
SO MEMBER CARLA- FOR TWENTY
YEARS YOU NEED TO CARE IS
PROVIDED HOUSING MENTAL HEALTH
IN SUPPORT OF SERVICE TO
THOUSANDS OF FOSTER YOUTH AND
EMERGING ADULTS. THROUGHOUT
NINE COUNTIES IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. WE HAD A LONG
HISTORY OF FIGHTING FOR.
SYSTEMIC RACISM FIGHT AGAINST
IMMIGRATION WITHIN THE FOSTER
CARE JUVENILE JUSTICE MENTAL
SYSTEMS THAT DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACT BLACK AND BROWN. YOUNG
MEN THAT PUT THEM ON A PATHWAY
TO PRISON FROM FOSTER CARE TO
PRISON WE TALK A LOT ABOUT. THE
PIPELINE BUT WE DON'T TALK
ABOUT FOSTER PRISON. I WILL
GIVE YOU A QUICK STORY A YOUNG
MAN- NAME DANTE TURNED TWENTY
ONE. IN FEBRUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY. HE MOVED INTO HIS OWN
APARTMENT AFTER LEAVING FOSTER
CARE. HE HAD A JOB- A MONTH
LATER HIS GRANDMOTHER CAME DOWN
OF COVERT. A MONTH AFTER THAT
HE LOST HIS JOB TWO MONTHS
AFTER THAT HE RECEIVED A THIRTY
DAY NOTICE TO VACATE HIS
APARTMENT BECAUSE HE NO LONGER
HAD INCOME. DANTE IN UP IN THE
HOSPITAL HE HAD HIS FIRST BREAK
OF PSYCHIATRIC PSYCHIATRIC
BRINK. DANTE IS AN EXAMPLE. OF
MANY OF OUR YOUNG FOLKS IN THE
FOSTER SYSTEM THAT LEAVE THE
SYSTEM WITHOUT THE PROPER
LEVELS OF SUPPORT. THINK ABOUT
THE DATA 4250% OF OUR KIDS
LEAVE FOSTER CARE ABOUT
GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL.
23210% GO OFF TO COLLEGE. 50%
WITHIN FOUR YEARS OF NO
EARNINGS. AND WE THINK ABOUT
OUR PRISON POPULATION JUST AS
WE JUST HEARD FROM PRIOR PANEL
80% OF FEDERAL AND STATE PRISON
THE PRISONERS HAVE NO HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA SO WE THINK
ABOUT THE FUTURE OF WHO THOSE
SHOOTERS ARE AND WHO'S WHO IS
THAT COMMUNITIES CAN BE
IMPACTED OUR PRISON SYSTEMS
IT'S OUR YOUNG FOLKS AT LEAVE
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM- WITHOUT
HOPE. A CHILD GROWING UP
WITHOUT HOPE BECAUSE THE CHILD
HAS TO SURVIVE WHEN THEY GET
OUT THERE ON THE STREETS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE NO OTHER
OPTIONS. WHEN THE PANDEMIC HIT
IT WAS YET ANOTHER BLOW. TO A
TRAUMATIZED POPULATION. IN
FOSTER CARE THE GEORGIA FLORIDA
THE SOCIAL UNREST. THEN THE
PANDEMIC AND THEN THE LACK OF
ACCESS TO TRAUMA AND CULTURALLY
PROFICIENT MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. SO AS AN ORGANIZATION
IN APRIL TWENTY TWENTY WE
LAUNCHED INITIATIVE HEALTH
INITIATIVE IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
SILICON VALLEY BLACK LEADERSHIP
KITCHEN CABINET THE SILICON
VALLEY COMMUNITY FOUNDATION
CALLED COVERT NINETEEN BLACK.
OUR GOAL WAS TO RAISE AWARENESS
OF COVERT NINETEEN AND REDUCE
THE SPREAD OF THE DEADLY VIRUS
WITHIN THE AFRICAN ANSWERS TO
COMMUNITY WE CREATED A
NARRATIVE THAT WE TOLD OUR OWN
STORIES VIDEO COLLAGES OF OUR
YOUNG FOLKS TALK ABOUT THE
IMPACTED THEM. AND HOW DO WE
PRODUCE HOW DO WE- REDUCE THE
SPREAD SO THAT OUR COMMUNITY IS
EDUCATED NOT ON WHAT WE SEE ON
SOCIAL MEDIA NOT ON THE
FALLACIES NANA WHAT THEY HEARD
THE BARBERSHOP BUT WHERE THE
TRUE FACTS ABOUT IT. WE LOST IS
INITIATIVE THROUGHOUT THE BAY
AREA. AND WE LAUNCHED IT WITH A
TOWN HALL EVENT THAT HAD OVER
TWO THOUSAND PEOPLE IN
ATTENDANCE. AGAIN OUR GOAL WAS
LET LET LET OUR YOUNG FOLKS
TELL THE STORIES. ABOUT THE
TRUCE AND THE FACTS ABOUT KOBE
NINETEEN. WE ALSO TALKED ABOUT
THE BACKPACKS OF TRAUMA BECAUSE
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT OUR KIDS
AND OUR YOUNG FOLKS IN
PARTICULAR AFRICAN AMERICANS
WHO ARE OVER REPRESENTED IN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED IN
EVERY LEVEL OF OUR SYSTEM. THE
BACKPACKS OF TRAUMA FROM
EDUCATION TO HEALTH. TO LEGAL
TO HOUSING- THOSE ARE ALL
THINGS THAT IMPACT AND WEIGH
HEAVY ON OUR COMMUNITIES ON
COVERT HIT IT WAS LIKE A TWELVE
ROUND BOXING MATCH AND HERE
COMES MIKE TYSON AND THIRTEENTH
ROUND. AND IT WAS A KNOCKOUT
BLOW. SO FOR US THIS WAS ABOUT
EDUCATE OUR COMMUNITY SO THAT
WE UNDERSTAND THE IMPACTS OF
HEALTH AND WHAT CAN WE DO TO
STRING THING AND MAKE BETTER
DECISIONS FOR OURSELVES SO THAT
OUR COMMUNITY. CAN PROTECT
OURSELVES AND PROTECT ELEVEN SO
FAR YOUNG BLACK AND OUR YOUNG
MEN OF COLOR AFRICAN AMERICAN-
AND EMERGING ADULTS. WITHOUT
EDUCATION THEY ARE LEFT TO LEAN
ON INFORMATION THAT COMES TO
SOCIAL MEDIA OFTENTIMES WE KNOW
IS NOT NOT CORRECT OR IS
MISLEADING BECAUSE OF THE
CENTURIES OF INEQUALITIES THAT
HAVE IMPACTED HOW WE BELIEVE
AND TRUST IN OUR SYSTEMS. THAT
HAVE FAILED US FOR CENTURIES
AND SO THIS INITIATIVE HAS BEEN
A MAJOR IMPACT TO OUR ABILITY
TO MAKE SURE OUR FOLKS HAVE
EDUCATION AND THEY HAVE
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW TO MAKE
THE PROPER DECISIONS. DO WE GET
ACCESS OR DO WE NOT WE SEE THIS
WE SEE THE SPIKE RIGHT NOW-
THAT'S THE REALITY THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH EVERY SINGLE DAY
WITH OUR PROGRAMS. SO WE HAVE
TRAINED THERAPISTS THAT FOCUS
ON CULTURALLY COMPETENT-
THERAPEUTIC INTERVENTIONS- WE
HAVE HOUSING THAT LOOK THAT IS
THROUGHOUT NINE DIFFERENT VERY
COUNTIES WE HOUSE OVER A
HUNDRED FIFTY YOUNG FOLKS- IN
ALL OF OUR PROGRAMS WE OFFER.
CASE MANAGEMENT SUPPORT THE
FOCUS ON THEIR EDUCATION THEIR
EMPLOYMENT SO THEY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY OF GETTING
CONNECTED TO AND SEE A VISION
OF THEMSELVES NOT WHAT IT WAS
YESTERDAY BUT WHAT THE VISION
CAN LOOK LIKE IN THE FUTURE.
ALSO HOW DO WE DO WITH THE
TRAUMA THAT OFTENTIMES WE DON'T
THINK ABOUT THOSE THINGS THAT
WE JUST SHOW UP AND DO THINGS
AND ALL REALIZE THAT'S BECAUSE
OF HISTORICAL TRAUMA AND HOW IS
IT SHOW UP TODAY. AND THEN HOW
WE WORK FOR EMPLOYERS OR
EMPLOYERS UNDERSTAND HOW TO
ENGAGE WITH A YOUNG PERSON THAT
DOESN'T HAVE ANYONE TO CALL ON
A SUNDAY AT. AT SIX O'CLOCK TO
HELP THEM WITH A WITH A FLAT
TIRE BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
THE FAMILY STRUCTURE OR THOSE
LEVELS OF SUPPORT CENTER IN
PLACE. SO OUR PROGRAM IS REALLY
ABOUT MAKING SURE WE GIVE OUR
YOUNG FOLKS A VISION FOR WHAT
THE FUTURE COULD LOOK LIKE AND
HOW DO WE THEN ACCESS THAT. AND
WHERE THEY ARE ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND HOW TRAUMA SHOWS UP
IN THEIR EVERYDAY LIFE BUT
OFTEN TIMES IT JUST BECOMES. A
COMMON PRACTICE OF HOW HOW THEY
DEAL WITH THE LOSSES THAT IF
EXPERIENCED GOING UP TO THE
FAUCET. SYSTEM SO I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THIS MOMENT THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY GET
ENOUGH ALLOW UNITY HERE TO
SPEAK WHAT'S PROGRAMS. AND I'LL
NOW TURN IT BACK OVER TO THE
PANEL.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
JAMES JONES. SAWYER AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JOSE FEET
OUT ABOUT OTHER MEN THAT AND
IT'S BEEN MY HONOR TO LEAD THE
WORK OF SAFE PASSAGES FOR THE
LAST EIGHTEEN YEARS. AND IT'S
MY HONOR TO DATE TODAY TO SPEAK
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE. OUR
ORGANIZATION IS A MULTI SERVICE
ORGANIZATION LOCATED IN OAKLAND
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT EIGHTEEN. LED
BY WOMEN OF COLOR WITH OVER
TWENTY SIX YEARS OF
DEMONSTRATED EFFECTIVE SERVICE
TO COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IN
OAKLAND OTHER HIGH NEED AREAS
OF ALAMEDA COUNTY. WE DELIVER A
COMPREHENSIVE RANGE OF
CULTURALLY RELEVANT SERVICES TO
OVER FOUR THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
CHILDREN YOUTH AND FAMILIES
EACH YEAR. OUR LAW AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE LIFE COACHING PROJECT.
AND GET ACTIVE PROGRAMS OUR
COMMUNITY TO FIND EVIDENCE
PRACTICES ARE LIFE COACHING
PROJECT IS ONE OF THE THIRTY
FIVE. COMMUNITY TO FIND
EVIDENCE PRACTICE IS FUNDED
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA REDUCING
DISPARITIES PROJECT WITHIN THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH EQUITY IN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT. OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. THEIMPACT OF
COVERT NINETEEN. ON THE
FAMILIES AND YOUTH THAT WE
SERVE. AND THE LARGER COMMUNITY
HAVE BEEN BOTH IMMEDIATE AND
ACUTE. THE MAJORITY OF YOUNG
PEOPLE SERVICE THROUGH OUR
PROGRAMS LIVE IN A TEN SCHOOLS
IN THE OAKLAND ZIP CODES WITH
THE HIGHEST RATES OF COVERT
NINETEEN INFECTION IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY. THE LAUNCH ALSO JUSTICE
PROJECT IS A PREVENTION AND
EARLY INTERVENTION PROGRAM THAT
AIMS TO PREVENT. AND REDUCE THE
EFFECTS OF EXPOSURE TO CHRONIC
STRESS INCLUDING TRAUMA
ASSOCIATED WITH POVERTY
EXPOSURE TO RACISM BEING
DISENFRANCHISED AND JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM INVOLVED AMONG
YOUTH OF COLOR PRIMARILY
AFRICAN AMERICAN AND LATIN NEXT
YOUTH AGES SIXTEEN TO TWENTY
ONE. WHO ARE JUDICATA SYSTEMS
INVOLVED ARE AT RISK OF
BECOMING SYSTEMS INVOLVED. THE
DATA CLEARLY L. ILLUSTRATES THE
EXTREME LEVEL OF POVERTY CRIME
VIOLENCE DISCRIMINATION AND
DISENFRANCHISEMENT EXPERIENCED
BY ADJUDICATED YOUTH OF COLOR
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. AND THE
CHRONIC STRESS PRODUCED BY
THESE OPPRESSIVE CONDITIONS.
CHRONIC STRESS BECOMES TOXIC
FOR OUR TARGET POPULATION
GREATLY INCREASING THE RISK OF
EXPERIENCING SYSTEMS ASSOCIATED
WITH TRAUMA. AND MENTAL ILLNESS
THE LAUNCH WILL SHUT SOCIAL
JUSTICE LIFE COACHING PROJECT
PROVIDES EFFECTIVE TRAUMA
INFORMED CULTURALLY COMPETENT
LIFE COACHING TO REDUCE TOXIC
STRESS LEVELS AND INCREASE
SUPPORT TO MITIGATE THE
PARTICIPANTS RISK ASSIST
SYMPTOMS ASSOCIATED. WITH THAT
TRAUMA AND MENTAL ILLNESS
SPECIFICALLY THE PROJECT
STRIVES TO INCREASE AND IMPROVE
COPING SKILLS SELF REGULATION
RELATIONSHIPS WITH CARING
ADULTS ACCESS TO SERVICES
EMPLOYMENT AND FAMILY
ENGAGEMENT. SIMPLY STATED THE
PROJECT COMPONENTS ARE DESIGNED
TO ELIMINATE THE STRESS AND
TRAUMA ASSOCIATED WITH BEING IN
THE FOSTER YOUTH JUVENILE
JUSTICE AND EDUCATION SYSTEMS.
THAT THE AREA OF CHANGE IS
DRIVEN BY STRATEGIES TO PREVENT
YOUTH AGES SIXTEEN TO TWENTY
ONE FROM ENTERING OR RE
ENTERING THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM AND EFFECTIVELY NAVIGATE
BUREAUCRATIC INEQUITABLE
SYSTEMS. LIKE FOSTER CARE
JUVENILE JUSTICE PUBLIC HEALTH
HEALTH CARE AND EDUCATION TO
ENSURE THAT YOU SUCCESSFULLY
EXIT THE SYSTEMS WITH THE
ASSETS REQUIRED TO SUCCEED. THE
PROJECT WAS DESIGNED TO DISRUPT
THE SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE
IN ITS LONG LASTING MENTAL
IMPLICATIONS FOR YOUTH OF COLOR
BY PRIORITIZING RESOURCES
WITHIN THE MODEL TO. HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATION AND THE
POTENTIAL FOR ECONOMIC MOBILITY
THE PRO THE PROJECT HAS FIVE
KEY COMPONENTS THE FIRST ONE IS
OUT REACH IN COORDINATION WHICH
OCCURS ON A CONTINUOUS BASIS IT
INCLUDES WORKING WITH PUBLIC
SYSTEMS PARTNERS AS WELL AS
TARGET SCHOOL COMMUNITIES OTHER
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND FAMILIES. TO SUPPORT
REFERRALS OF RECRUITMENT
COORDINATION INTEGRATION OF
SERVICES AT TARGET SCHOOLS AND
IN THE COMMUNITY NUMBER TWO
ENROLLMENT LIFE COACHES FOLLOW
REVIEWER FOR A FOLLOW UP ON
REFERRALS AND WHAT SCHOOLS
COMMUNITY BASED AND SYSTEMS
PARTNERS. AND WORK WITH
FAMILIES PAYING CLOSE ATTENTION
TO SCREEN FOR TRAUMA AND
RELATED SYSTEMS NUMBER THREE
LIFE COACHING CASE MANAGEMENT
THESE ACTIVITIES ARE DESIGNED
TO PROVIDE YOUTH WITH THE
SKILLS REQUIRED TO NAVIGATE THE
MULTIPLE PUBLIC SYSTEMS THEY
HAVE TO ENCOUNTER. LIKE
JUVENILE JUSTICE LAW
ENFORCEMENT PUBLIC BENEFITS
HEALTH CARE AND EDUCATION IN A
WAY THAT EMPOWERS THEM
ACTIVITIES INCLUDE COACHING
MODELING FOR AND MENTORING
YOUTH ACCOMPANIMENT TO PUBLIC
SYSTEMS APPOINTMENTS DIRECT
ASSISTANCE WITH SECURING
GATEWAY DOCUMENTS LIKE DRIVER'S
LICENSES BIRTH CERTIFICATES
WORK PERMITS. THAT GIVE THE
YOUNG PEOPLE GREATER AGENCY IN
DEALING WITH PUBLIC SYSTEMS
ASSISTANCE TO RECONNECT WITH-FAMILY TREATING THEM LIKE
FAMILY AND CONDUCTING ONE ON
ONE LIFE COACHING AND
COUNSELLING SESSIONS WITH THEM.
NUMBER FOUR LIFE SKILLS AND
ETHNIC STUDIES INCLUDES
EDUCATION ABOUT ETHNIC STUDIES
TO INCREASE PROTECTORS IN THE
YOUNG PERSON TO COUNTER THE
TOXIC STRESS PRODUCED BY THE
INHERENT IN EQUITIES IN THE
SYSTEMS. THAT THEY HAVE TO DEAL
WITH PARTICIPANTS LEARN ABOUT
THEIR HISTORY CULTURE AND THE
RIGHTS THEY HAVE IN TERMS OF
THE SUB PUBLIC SYSTEMS THAT
THEY HAVE TO WORK THROUGH. MANY
OF THE CLASSES ARE TAUGHT
THROUGH CONCURRENT ENROLLMENT
THAT PROVIDES PARTICIPANTS WITH
BOTH HIGH SCHOOL AND COLLEGE
CREDIT. AND THEN THE LAST
COMPONENT IS FAMILY ENGAGEMENT
IN WITHIN THIS COMPONENT THE
CORE BELIEF IS THAT THE
FAMILIES THAT THAT THE FAMILY
CAN BE THE CORE SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT FOR CHILDREN AND YOUTH.
STRENGTHENING THE FAMILY
SUPPORT SYSTEM IS THE BEST
STRATEGY FOR TRYING TO ENSURE
THAT YOUTH WILL HAVE A LIFETIME
OF SUPPORT LONG AFTER
PARTICIPANTS EXIT OUR
PROGRAMMING AND WE KNOW THAT
FAMILIES CAN NOT FULLY ENGAGING
SERVICES UNLESS BASIC NEEDS ARE
MET THIS IS NEVER BEEN MORE
APPARENT THAN DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. FOR EXAMPLE FAMILIES
CANNOT ATTEND SCHOOL EVENTS IF
HOUSING AND FOOD NEEDS ARE NOT
SECURE. I'D LIKE TO JUST SHARE
A COUPLE OF BRIEF OUTCOMES WE
JUST COMPLETED A THREE YEAR
STUDY OF OUR AFRICAN AMERICAN
YOUTH PARTICIPANTS IN WHICH
SIXTY THREE PARTICIPANTS WERE
FOLLOWED. A 100% OF THESE
PARTICIPANTS GRADUATED FROM
HIGH SCHOOL AND NONE OF THEM
ZERO WE ENTERED OUR ENTERED THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM AFTER
PARTICIPATING IN THIS PROGRAM.
AND TWO RECOMMENDATIONS I
WANTED TO SHARE WITH THE
COMMITTEE ABOUT SUSTAINABILITY
AND SCALABILITY IS WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TARGET. UP STATE
FEDERAL RESOURCES IN THE
PROGRAMS THAT WORK AND I WOULD
STRONGLY INCH COURAGE THE
COMMISSION THANK THE COMMITTEE
THE SELECT COMMITTEE TO LOOK AT
THE MENTAL SERVICE THAT MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT AND THE
PREVENTION EARLY INTERVENTION
REGULATIONS AND CREATE SPACE
FOR COMMUNITY TO FIND. EVIDENCE
BASED PRACTICES AND ALSO TO
LOOK AT THE NEW INVESTMENT IN
SCHOOL BASED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
HEALTH AND TO CONSIDER A CARVE
OUT WITH IN THE FOUR BILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT FOR YOUTH OF
COLOR MARGINALIZED AND
HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED WITHIN
THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM AND TO ENSURE THAT
COMMUNITY TO FIND EVIDENCE
BASED PRACTICES CAN BE FUNDED
THROUGH BOTH OF THESE REALLY
CRITICAL. EXISTING AND NEW
FUNDING SOURCES THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY THANK YOU VERY BROUGH
INFORMATION THANK YOU. AND NEXT
IS THAT A DOCTOR BARBER. YES
YEAH SURE WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
TO. OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON IS A
LIMIT OF ASTORIA I AM VERY
DELIGHTED TO BE HERE AN HONOR
TO BE HERE AND I AM DOCTOR JACK
BARBER 'M A COMMUNITY
PSYCHIATRIST AND UP CODE OF.
FOUNDED THE ORGANIZATION SOME
TWENTY EIGHT YEARS AGO TO SERVE
OF BALD EAGLE POPULATIONS IN
SOUTH LOS ANGELES ADULT.
CHILDREN OLDER ADULTS AND MOST
RECENTLY WITH THE EPIDEMIC OF
HOMELESSNESS- OUR EMPHASIS ON
THAT POPULATION AS WELL. SO I
THOUGHT I'D LIKE TO DO IS JUST
DESCRIBED TO YOU ALL TWELVE
YEAR OLD BLACK YOUNG MAN NAMED
MARK MARCUS WAS ABUSE. MARCUS
LIVES WITH A FOSTER FAMILY WITH
IT AND HAS A DEEP. YEARNING TO
REUNITE REUNITE WITH HIS FAMILY
HIS MOTHER IS INCARCERATED HIS
FATHER'S ESTABLISHED ANOTHER
FAMILY OUT OF STATE. ARGUS WAS
DESPONDENT ATTITUDE OF THE
SCHOOL AND THE LAST ACTION
FIGURES. ARGUS RECEIVE
WRAPAROUND APPROACH SERVICE
WRAPAROUND IS A NATIONAL MODEL
BUT IT'S A BEST PRACTICE
EVIDENCE BASED APPROACH THAT
HAS AS ITS CORE VALUE THE CHILD
AND FAMILY VOICE AND CHOICE AND
SERVICES THAT ARE FOCUSED ON
WHAT THE CHILD AND FAMILY WANT
TO. MOST RECENTLY THIS IS
KEEPING. CHILDREN IN YEARS AND
THEIR HOMES AND FAMILIES AND
OUR TEAM WORKS AS VICTIMS
FAMILY MEMBERS. AS A TEAM
APPROACH THAT INCLUDES SERVICES
THAT START WITH A FACILITATE
THE WORST EXPAND THE NETWORKS
OF THE CHILD AND FAMILY AND HE
AND THE FACILITATOR IS AWARE OF
COMMUNITY RESOURCES AS FOR IT
FREQUENTLY A COMMUNITY CHAMPION.
IT ALSO INCLUDES A CHILD AND
FAMILY THERAPIST WHO IS WELL
TRAINED IN TRAUMA INFORMED CARE.
IT INCLUDES A VERY IMPORTANT
PARA PART WHICH MEANS A
SOMEBODY WHO HAS LIVED
EXPERIENCE. AND IF NECESSARY. I
CHILD ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRISTS.
THERE IS MUCH EVIDENCE
CORROBORATING THE AFFECTIVE
NOUS OF YOUR SUPPORT SURPLUS
DOESN'T IN FACT THERE'S EVEN
STATEWIDE LEGISLATION THAT-
LEGITIMIZES THE HOPE THAT WORK
AS A IMPORTANT MENTAL HEALTH
TEAM MEMBER IN THE
ARMAMENTARIUM OF SERVICES THAT
ARE AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING TRAUMA. FROM UP
FOR OUR PARA PARTNERS THIS
MEANS THEY HAVE HAD PERSONAL
INTERACTION WITH FOSTER CARE
DPSS OR MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
THIS MEANS THEY KNOW THE
SYSTEMS FROM A LIVED EXPERIENCE
POINT OF VIEW AND I CAN HELP
NAVIGATE THOSE SYSTEMS. THE
PROFILE OF A BLACK WRAPAROUND
CHEAP AS I MENTIONED THOSE
THOSE THOSE PARTICIPANTS BUT BE
HAVING SOMEONE WHO LOOKS LIKE.
THE CHILD ARE YOU. S.
CONVERSANT WITH THE CULTURAL
ENVIRONMENT. THIS IS FREQUENTLY
THE PAIR TEAM IS BLACK OR BROWN
HAVE A DEEP UNDERSTANDING OF
THE JOURNEY AT INDIVIDUAL ICE
PLANS OF CARE ARE MONITORED.
THIS THERE IS IMPORTANT
FLEXIBLE FUNDING TO SUPPORT THE
CHILD AND FAMILY THIS MEANS WE
CAN SPEND TARGETED
INTERVENTIONS. WHEN WE NEED IT.
THIS IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE OF
THE ECONOMICS AND SYSTEMIC
PROBLEMS WITH HOUSING AND
SECURITY FOOD SECURITY SO THAT
MEANS THAT WE ACTUALLY OPERATE
AS A- OFFICE FOR ON THE ON OUT
ON THE ON ON THE NEEDS OF THE
CHILD SO THAT HAVE SCRIPT THERE
IS A HOUSING SITUATION THE NEED
SAFE OUTSIDE WE ARE ABLE TO
QUICKLY PROVIDE IT AND TRYING
THAT IN THE COMMUNITY. ABOUT
MARCUS BECAUSE HE BENEFIT FROM
THE TEAM WORKING WITH THE- WITH
WITH WORKING INTIMATELY WITH
TEACHERS AND PROMOTING HIS
ATTEMPTS. TUTORING AND
MENTORING FOR SCHOOL SUPPLIES
BASICALLY RECREATIONAL
ACTIVITIES WERE CAREFULLY
CRAFTED. THROUGH THROUGH THE
INDIVIDUALIZED PLAN AND YOU
KNOW HIS HIS DEEP AFFECTION I
MUST SAY FOR ACTION FIGURES LED
TO A WEEKEND TRIP TO COMIC CON
WHICH NORMALIZES A LOT OF- IN
OPENING THEIR BEST. SO THE
WHOLE TREATMENT DOWN FOR THE
WEEKEND TO SAN DIEGO TO
EXPERIENCE THAT THIS IS AND
WENT AND WE WERE ABLE TO PAY
FOR. SO LET ME TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE COMMUNITY
SUPPORTS FROM MARCUS THAT
INCLUDE FAMILY INVOLVEMENT IN
THE PROGRAM SPECIFICALLY.
DESIGNED FOR BLACK PARENTS
PROJECT FATHERHOOD IS A SUPPORT
GROUP AND MENTORING
ORGANIZATION. THAT DISCUSSES
HOW PARENTS CAN STRATEGIZE TO
ORGANIZE BETTER COMMUNITY
SPORTS. AFTER TWENTY PLUS YEARS
MORE THAN FIFTEEN THOUSAND
FATHERS HAVE PARTICIPATE. AT
OUR FATHERS AND FAMILY ATTEND A
WATCH PROJECT FATHER. MANY OF
OUR STAFF ARE FACILITATORS AND
CARD CARRYING MEMBERS OF THIS
ORGANIZATION AND THEREFORE
THEY- DON'T THEM AS A COMMUNITY
SUPPORT. WRAPAROUND THIS IS
ANOTHER PARTNER RATE UP
EXPERIENCE ALL BLOOM WHICH IS
CALLED BUILDING A LIFETIME OF
OPTIONS AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR
MEN LITTLE. SUPPORT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY FOUNDATION
AND THE BROTHERHOOD. IT'S
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSES POLICIES
AND CONSCIOUS THAT LEADS TO
CHRONIC JUDICIAL AND PROBATION-
INVOLVEMENT AND RESHAPES THE
PERCEPTION OF BLACKMAIL YOU.
WITH ALL THESE INTERVENTIONS
THOUGH IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW
THAT THEIR INCORPORATED INTO
WRAPPED AROUND AND THE
WRAPAROUND IS LIKE A
HELICOPTER. YOU CAN RAISE OR
LOWER ITS ALTITUDE DEPENDING ON
BEHAVIOR AND IT HAS THE JET
FUEL UP FINANCIAL SUPPORT FOR
SAFE HOUSE MAKING FOOD SECURITY
AND THE LIGHT. SO MARKETS DID
WELL WITH THE COMMUNITY
SUPPORTS INVOLVED HE'S EIGHTEEN
THAT. HIS VOICE AND- LED TO A
GOAL TO GO TO COLLEGE OUTSIDE
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ULTIMATELY HE WAS ACCEPTED TO
PENN STATE. AND I HAVE NO IDEA
HOW REALLY THEY THEY ALL CAME
TO AFTER THAT WAS AN
INTERESTING CHOICE AND THE TEAM
SUPPORTED HIS DECISION. IRAN
BROWN HAS PAID HIS FIRST YEAR
OF TO WHICH. YOU STILL
CONNECTED TO HIS FAMILY AT
SHARP I WAS MADE SOME
CONNECTIONS TO HIS FATHER AND
HIS FOSTER PLACEMENT WAS
ENHANCED BY MOMENTS OF FAMILY
RESPITE. AND ECONOMIC SUPPORTS
AS I'VE MENTIONED AND PLEASE
KNOW THAT SAVES HOUSING.
ASSEMBLY ENVIRONMENT IS
SUPERIOR TO RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT FACILITIES WHICH
RANGE FROM A THOUSAND TO FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS A DAY. BEFORE
I CONCLUDE MY REMARKS ABOUT
MARCUS AND SPECIALIZED FOSTER
CARE AND WRAPAROUND I WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT THE WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE ON BLACK PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HAWKINS. THE
TWENTY SIXTEEN REPORT REVEALED
THAT APPROXIMATELY 40% OF OUR
IN HOUSE INDIVIDUALS ARE BLACK
AND THIRTY EIGHT PERCENT. OF
THE U. R. WE FEEL THAT WRAP
AROUND SHOULD BE SCALED UP TO
ADDRESS THE INFLOW OF OUR
CHILDREN GROW HOMES LACKS
SPECIALIZED FOSTER CARE
CHILDREN COULD RECEIVES
PURPOSES WITH THE ASSISTANCE OF
YOU WITH LIVED EXPERIENCE IT'S
THAT SAME MODEL TO REDUCE THESE
NUMBERS. ANSWERED TO MAKE SOME
STOPS STOPS ON THE HIGHWAY
BETWEEN HOMELESSNESS AND
SPECIALIZED FOSTER CARE AND
INCARCERATION. BECAUSE THERE IS
THIS DESTRUCTIVE AND LOOK THAT
UP THAT IS VERY STIRRING TO THE
SLOW. THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
WELL IN OUR FINAL PANELIST IS
DR YUTAKA SPRINGER. WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. GOOD AFTERNOON-
DR YUTAKA SPRINGER AND THE
CLINICAL BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTOR AND A PSYCHOLOGIST AT
NATIVE AMERICAN HEALTH CENTER-
WE'RE IN FEDERALLY QUALIFIED
HEALTH CENTER- IN SAN FRANCISCO
AN OPEN SERVING ABOUT FIFTEEN
THOUSAND PEOPLE- PER YEAR.
THESE ARE MOSTLY- LOW INCOME
MEDICAL RECIPIENTS- AND MANY
WOULD ASSUME BY OUR NAME THAT
WE SERVE ONLY NATIVE AMERICAN-
COMMUNITY MEMBERS BUT-
CERTAINLY IT'S A VERY DIVERSE-
BY COP BY PA COMMUNITY THAT WE
SERVE- I OUR GREATEST SEGMENT
IS LATIN ACTS- AND THEN
FOLLOWED BY A MIXTURE OF
AFRICAN AMERICAN PEOPLE AND-
RECENTLY IMMIGRATED ASIANS-
THAT WITH ABOUT A PROBABLY
ABOUT 15% ACTUALLY- AMERICAN
INDIANS AND ALASKA NATIVES- SO
I JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT- TO
PREVENTION PROGRAMS IN OUR
COMMUNITY WELLNESS DEPARTMENT
HEADED BY SOME AMAZING LEADERS-
INTER AGENCY. THAT ARE
EFFECTIVE IN REACHING OUR BY
PARK MEN AND BOYS WITH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH RISKS- AND
MANY OF WHOM ARE
DISENFRANCHISED AND NOT
CONNECTING WITH- CLINICAL
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES
PSYCHOLOGICAL SERVICES THOSE
KIND OF ONE ON ONE- COUNSELING
SERVICES- SO THE FIRST PROGRAM
IS- ARE STRONG FAMILIES- TRIBAL
HOME VISITING PROGRAM THIS LED
BY SHOULD BE COULD DO X. BROWN
IS AMAZING- LEADER AND- IT
SUPPORTS- PREGNANT. AND
PARENTING FAMILIES OF NATIVE
CHILDREN ZERO TO FIVE- WHY ARE
WE FOCUSING ON- YOUNG FAMILIES.
WE KNOW THIS IS A REALLY
CRITICAL PHASE- GET NEW
PARENTHOOD IS A- VERY STRESSFUL
AND EXPENSIVE PHASE THAT HAS
LONG TERM EFFECTS ON THE NEXT
GENERATION- VERY CRITICAL
ATTACHMENT WINDOWS- THAT CAN
IMPACT- THOSE FUTURE-
GENERATIONS AND WE JUST. WANNA
SHAPE HEALTHY BEHAVIORS AND
PARENTING PRACTICES- WE HAVE A
SOLID EVIDENCE BASED
CURRICULUM- WE CONNECT PEOPLE
TO RESOURCES HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. VIOLENCE AND
ADDICTION PROGRAMS- AND JUST
HOLDEN SHAPE FAMILIES- SO THE
NEXT GEN GENERATION AND THE
COMMUNITY CAN BE HAPPIER AND
HEALTHIER- AND SPECIFIC TO-
FATHERS OF COLOR IN OUR PROGRAM.
REALLY SEEKING TO BUILD-
ADAPTIVE SUPPORTS FOR THEM
LINKING FATHERS TO EACH OTHER
AND REGULAR TALKING CIRCLES
MEDIATED BY RESPECTED COMMUNITY
ELDERS- TO DEVELOP A SUPPORT
NETWORK- THE IDEA THAT
FATHERHOOD IS A TYPE OF
BROTHERHOOD- AND- WITH
INCREASED CONNECTION- COMES
INCREASED- MENTAL HEALTH AND
RESILIENCY- SO PAUL MILLAR
THERE SOON EXCELLENT JOB- BUT-
THROUGH. THROUGH THESE EFFORTS
WE'VE WE'VE SEEN SOME REALLY
GREAT OUTCOMES AND JUST FIND
THAT- WHEN PEOPLE HAVE MORE
RESOURCES AND SUPPORT THEY CAN
YOU KNOW LEARN AND KEEP
ADAPTIVE SKILLS- AND WE'RE
WE'RE REALLY GATHERING A LOT OF
DATA THERE- TO PROVE OUR
OUTCOMES- THE SECOND PROGRAM I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT- IS CALED
GOING OVER THE GATHERING OF
NATIVE AMERICANS THIS IS- YOU
KNOW DECADES- WORTH OF WORK.
THE NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
EFFECTIVE GROUP TRAINING USING
INDIGENOUS METHODS SUCH AS
PRAYER STORE STORYTELLING-
DRUMMING TALKING CIRCLES AGAIN-
OFTEN MEDIATED BY COMMUNITY
ELDERS- AS ARTISTIC EXPRESSION-
SO WHAT'S THE GOAL FOR THIS
PROGRAM WE WANNA PARTICIPANTS-
AND WE MIGHT HAVE A FOCUS ON
YOUTH OR ADULTS OR THE FAMILY
UNIT- TO EXPERIENCE. FOR CORE
VALUES TO SEE YOU THROUGH THESE
ACTIVITIES WHICH-
UNFORTUNATELY- MANY HAVE NOT
EXPERIENCED BEFORE BUT-
BELONGING- WHICH IS A UNIVERSAL
NEED THAT MANY HAVE NOT- YEAH
EXPERIENCED SELF MASTERY-
INTERDEPENDENCE- AND GENEROSITY
SO- ARE BY PARK BEEN INVOICE
YOU PARTICIPATE DESCRIBED THIS
AS A VERY- POWERFUL AND
CONNECTING EXPERIENCE REALLY
TRANSFORMATIVE- THAT. PROMOTES
A STRONG SENSE OF COMMUNITY
CONNECTIVITY IN RESPONSIBILITY-
WHICH THEN BUILDS STRONGER
COMMUNITIES SO- AGAIN REALLY
MAKING AN EFFORT TOGETHER.
OUTCOME DATA- I TO. IN INCLINE
TO- THE PAS BENEFITS OF
PARTICIPATION IN IN GOING TO.
SO WHAT YOU WHAT YOU REALLY SEE
HERE ARE JUST TWO EXAMPLES OF
PROGRAMS WORKING UPSTREAM- TO
REACH BY APARTMENT INVOICE- TO
BUILD HEALTHIER AND MORE
CONNECTED FUTURE- FOR
COMMUNITIES AND HOPEFULLY
PROGRAMS LIKE THESE CAN JUST
CONTINUE TO IMPACT YOUR POLICY
DECISIONS- INVESTING IN
PREVENTION PROGRAMS OBVIOUSLY
MEANS FEWER ISSUES DOWNSTREAM
SO WE TALKED A LOT ABOUT THAT
TODAY A LOT OF- WISDOM HAS BEEN
SHARED- AND OBSERVATIONS BUT-
REALLY THE IDEA IS TO- BREAK.
CYCLES OF ABUSE INTER GENERALLY
INTRODUCED INTER
GENERATIONALLY- VIOLENCE
TRAUMA- CONNECT PEOPLE TO
SUBSTANCE- PROGRAMS- ADDRESS
SUICIDALITY FURTHER UPSTREAM-
I'M A CLINICAL PSYCHOLOGIST
AGAIN AND TO BE ABLE HEALTH
DIRECTOR AND MY GOAL WOULD BE
THAT NOBODY COMES TO MY DOOR.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
WORK AS UPSTREAM AS POSSIBLE-
AND OF COURSE THIS IN TURN
SAVES- SOCIETY MONEY BUT IT'S
SO MUCH MORE. THAN THAT. SO
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND I WOULD JUST BE REMISS IF I
DIDN'T SAY ONE FINAL THING
ABOUT TELEHEALTH- BEING IN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH- WE REALLY
SEE THIS. TECHNOLOGY IS
CRITICAL- TO REACHING SECTORS
OF THE COMMUNITY THAT
OTHERWISE- WOULD HAVE A REALLY
DIFFICULT TIME CONNECTING- AND
LIKE MANY WHEN WE ROLLED OUT
TELEHEALTH SERVICES. AFTER THE
LOCKDOWNS LAST MARCH- WE SAW A
50% INCREASE IN PAYROLL HEALTH
SERVICE UTILIZATION- BUT THIS
WAS. DISPROPORTIONATELY LARGER-
FOR MOST FINANCIALLY STRAINED
UNDER RESOURCE MEMBERS SO WE
ARE SEEING PEOPLE COME THROUGH
OUR DOOR VIRTUALLY- AT IN OVER
2100% INCREASE THAT IS ACTUALLY
MAINTAINED. THROUGHOUT OUR-
MAINTENANCE OF- TELEHEALTH
SERVICES- THAT JUST SPEAKS TO
THE CONVENIENCE- OF THE SAFETY
AND THE EFFECTIVE-
EFFECTIVENESS OF GETTING THESE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES THROUGH
THIS SO. I JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO THE GOVERNOR AND
FOR THE LEGISLATURE- FOR
APPROVING UTILIZATION OF
TELEHEALTH SERVICES THROUGH.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO WITH THE
CONTINUED WAIVER. THANK YOU-
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OUT AND I WILL JUST ADD
TO THE TELEHEALTH. OF DURING
THE PANDEMIC- IN MY COMMUNITY
AND MISS CAREERS COMMUNITY- WE
HAVE CLINICS WE DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE A WHOLE LOT
HOSPITALS. IN OUR CLINICS HAD
THE BURDEN OF- DEALING WITH
HEALTH CARE AND WE FOUND THAT-
I TELL HEALTH SERVICES LIKE
ESPECIALLY MY DISTRICT WE'RE IN
A LOT OF THE CLINICS ARE
GETTING TWENTY CALLS. YOU KNOW
A MONTH SHOT UP TO TWO
THOUSAND. IN IT LIKE THE FIRST
MONTH OF THE PANDEMIC AND IT'S
BEEN INCREASING AND THEY'VE
BEEN ABLE TO SERVICE OBVIOUSLY.
THOUSAND TIMES MORE THAN THEY
COULD BEFORE AND SO- WE
PROBABLY DO NEED TO CONTINUE TO
EXPLORE THIS TELEHEALTH FOR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE THAT THAT MAY BE A
SAVING GRACE I MEAN IF. IT
DEPICTS BEEN A PROBLEM BUT-
THIS TELEHEALTH THEY COULD BE
SOMETHING. THAT COULD TAKE US
IN IN PLACES THAT WE NEVER KNEW
BEFORE IT COULD BE VERY
HELPFUL. FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES SO THANK YOU AND
THEN. JUST JUST FOR ME TO
DECIDE KNOW THE DIFFERENCE AND
SINCE WE GOT SO MANY DOCTORS
HERE RIGHT NOW- MENTAL HEALTH
VERSUS BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
WHAT'S IS THERE A DIFFERENCE
WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE OR READ.
ANYWAY ANYBODY CAN TAKE- I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT- ZERO
HEALTH I THINK THERE'S BEEN
MORE OF A SHIFT TOWARD AGAIN
LIKE MEASUREMENT AND
QUANTIFICATION THAT'S EASIER TO
DO WITH BEHAVIOR THAN MENTAL
PROCESSES WHICH I THINK A LOT
OF PEOPLE- MIGHT SAY OUR- LOOK
A LITTLE HARDER TO OBSERVE OR
QUANTIFY- THAT THAT WOULD
PROBABLY BE ONE THING BUT WE
KNOW THAT YOU KNOW THOUGHTS ARE
SO LINKED TO BEHAVIORS AND WE
WANT TO BE AS OBJECTIVE AS
POSSIBLE- REALLY KIND OF
FOCUSING ON BEHAVIOR. CAN TAKE
A- THIS ALSO REALLY SIMPLE
EXPLANATION OF PEOPLE SAY
MENTAL HEALTH AND THEN THEIR
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER AND SO
WHEN YOU SAY MENTAL HEALTH OR
NOT INCLUDING SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TREATMENT TO
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH IS A
COMBINATION OF BOTH OF THOSE.
THIRTY EASIER WAY TO ADDRESS
THAT BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT AN
INDIVIDUAL DOESN'T JUST. HALF
OF THEM SUFFERS FROM MENTAL
HEALTH AND HALF OF THEM SUFFERS
FROM A SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
IT'S THAT ONE PERSON IN
COUNTERING ALL OF THAT. IT'S A
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH OF THE NOT
RECOGNIZING THE WHOLE PERSON-
WHAT THEY EXPERIENCE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THE EXPLANATION.
OF THE DURING QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- MISTER KALRA.
YEAH THIS IS- LIKE ALL OF YOU A
HUGE CONCERN IN TERMS OF THE
PANDEMIC'S IMPACT ON THE APRIL
ESPECIALLY ON COMMUNITIES THAT
ALREADY TEND TO HAVE GREATER
TRAUMA. CERVANTES AUDREY MY
LIVING AS A PUBLIC DEFENDER
WHEN IT WITH ANY MY CLIENTS IF
YOU DIG DEEP INTO THEIR HISTORY
YOU'LL SEE MANY POINTS OF
TRAUMA THAT WERE NOT ADDRESSED
IN THEIR YOUTH. DEGREE MONTHS
OF AUSTRIA. IS MISS CHAPMAN
OWNS AND- BUT BUT THERE ARE A
GOING BACK TO THAT WAS ON THERE
ARE SIX MODEL. OF YOU KNOW
CARE'S ONE ARE NONE OF ANY
YEARS BUT IT'S A VERY.
EXPENSIVE TO DO ALL RIGHT YOU
CAN'T DO THIS WORK ON THE CHEAP.
AND SO- AB AND ADDING
TELEHEALTH IS A OPPORTUNITY TO
DO IT RIGHT IN A WAY THAT'S
ACCESSIBLE JUST LIKE A- WITH
THE CHAMBERS MANAGING MY
DISTRICT AS WELL AS WAS MOSTLY
CLINICS DOTTED RATHER HIM BE
SOLDERING THE PANDEMIC WHEN IT
COMES TO TESTING VACCINATIONS
THEY DIDN'T START THE CLINICS
THE END OF THE CLAIM WHICH THEY
SHOULD HAVE STARTED IN THE
CONTEXT THAT'S NOT HOT WE GOTTA
DO THIS RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO BE
INVESTING THIS MUCH AND IN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. I'M NOT JUST
A SUPPLEMENT FOR THOSE THAT
ALREADY HAVE TO GET TO THOSE
THAT THAT DON'T AND I THINK
THAT- THE INVESTMENT IS GOT TO
BE CONSISTENT- IT'S GONNA BE
PAYING- BECAUSE AGAIN- IT
DIVERSE FROM WHAT OTHERWISE IS
GOING TO BE A FAR MORE COSTLY
OUTCOME- WHETHER IT'S
HOMELESSNESS WEATHER'S CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM WHATEVER IT
MIGHT BE AND IT REALLY LEADS TO
THE NEXT PANEL AS WELL YOU HELP
TO DEAL WITH THE TRAUMA THE
BEHAVIOR HEALTH ISSUES THE
YOUNGER AGE AND THEN SUCH. AND
SET SOMEONE UP FOR THAT CAREER
PATH GOING FORWARD AND SO IT'S
ABOUT TWENTY INVEST IN THE
RIGHT PLACES AND I AND I
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF YOUR
DUES. THANK YOU. THIS CARILLO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. LOOKING THING ON. A
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENT- I
WANT TO PUT ON ON YOUR RADAR.
THAT I'M ACTUALLY I'M ACTUALLY
RUNNING A BILL ITS AB FOUR
SIXTY TWO- LICENSE CLINICAL
COUNSELORS. IT'S THE IT'S THE
EXPANSION OF THE PROGRAM THAT
ALLOWS FOR- THE TREATMENT OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INCLUDING
MENTAL HEALTH WHICH I JUST
SHARED. WE KNOW THAT OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO HAVE EXPERIENCED THE
MOST TRAUMA UNDER COBIT.
ESPECIALLY IN COMMUNITIES LIKE
OURS. WHERE ESSENTIAL IN FRONT
LINE WORKERS HAVE BEEN IMPACTED
THE MOST ESPECIALLY IF THEY
ARE. LATINO OR BLACK OR
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. AND SO
WE'RE HOPING THAT IN AN EFFORT
TO REMOVE SOME OF THE BARRIERS.
FOR LICENSED CLINICAL
COUNSELORS TO BE ABLE TO TREAT.
FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS THAT
NEED- A SCOPE OF SERVICES.
ACTUALLY ALLOWS FOR- BE THE
BARRIERS OF ENTRY TO RECEIVE
CARE TO BE REDUCED. AND SO- FOR
FOLKS OUT THERE IN THE
COMMUNITY HOPEFULLY. THIS MAKES
IT UP TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK
AND GET TO SIGNATURE SO THAT WE
CAN. NOT ONLY TALK ABOUT
PROVIDING THE RESOURCES BECAUSE
WITH THE PUT AS MUCH MONEY AS
WE WANTED TO- ALEC L. A. COUNTY
SPECIFICALLY FROM FOR ME AND
FOR THE CHAIR. BUT WITHOUT THE
PEOPLE TO DO THE WORK THAT
MONEY JUST SITS THERE. AND
DOESN'T GET UTILIZED AND SO WE
NEED THE WORK FORCE TO BE ABLE
TO DEVELOP- THE TREATMENT- IN
ADDITION TO THE STIGMA.
ASSOCIATED AROUND MENTAL HEALTH
AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE-
ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING REALLY HARD TO ENSURE
THAT. MENTAL HEALTH IS PART OF
THE CONVERSATIONS WITHIN
SCHOOLS. SO AND ONLY WITH THE
SPECIFICALLY- CREATING THE
MODEL FOR COMMUNITY CLINICS OR
I'M SORRY COMMUNITY THE
COMMUNITY SCHOOL APPROACH. IN
WHICH THESE RESOURCES ARE
AVAILABLE. AT THE AT THE SCHOOL
SITE. BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT'S
WHERE IT WHETHER IT'S FROM
ELEMENTARY ALL THE WAY UP TO
HIGH SCHOOL WE KNOW THAT THAT'S
WHERE. CHILDREN. FEEL THE
SAFEST THERE AMONG SIR. THEIR
MONSTER TEACH. AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS ARE INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT- ESPECIALLY AS WE
RETURNED. BACK TO SCHOOL AND SO
EVERYTHING THAT YOU DO THAT
SUPPORTS WHAT THE LEGISLATURE
IS DOING TO BRING. THESE
RESOURCES OUT INTO COMING INTO
THE COMMUNITY- IT'S CRITICAL.
AND SO IF YOU HAVE ADDITIONAL
IDEAS AS TO WHAT IT IS THAT WE
SHOULD BE DOING- HERE TO BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE
CONCERNS WERE OPEN BECAUSE YOU
KNOW THEY'RE THE FOLKS ON THE
GROUND. THAT ARE THAT ARE DOING
THE WORK NECESSARY AND- I JUST
WANT TO GIVE A PERSONAL SHOUT
OUT TO. MY SISTER MY SISTER'S A
WRAPAROUND SERVICES MENTAL
HEALTH PROVIDER WITH FOSTER
CHILDREN. AND WITH THAT AND
HOST FAMILIES THAT ARE RECENTLY
PLACED AN PROJECT ROOM HERE
PROJECT KAMKE. HER ROLE LIKE
MANY YOUNG WOMEN AND WOMEN OF
COLOR IS TO GO TO THE DOORS.
THE HOMES OF THESE FAMILIES AND
JUST CHECK IN ON THEM. AND
ENSURE THAT THEY ARE SAFE BUT
THEY HAVE RESOURCES- AND
ULTIMATELY I THINK WHAT WE NEED
IS A PLAN. IN WHICH- THE MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES HAVE
ACCESS O THE VACCINE. MY
SISTER HAS TOLD ME STORIES OF
VISITING FAMILIES OF A SINGLE
MOM WITH. FIVE CHILDREN UNDER
NINE WHO'S LIVING ON THE BRINK
OF. A POVERTY AND WHO DOESN'T
HAVE A CAR RELIES ON PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION. AND A LACK OF
CHILD CARE HAS NOT. GIVEN HER
THE ABILITY TO ACTUALLY RECEIVE
THE VACCINE PUTTING HERSELF AND
HER CHILDREN. ADD ADDITIONAL
RISKS AND WE KNOW THAT THAT IS
EXACTLY. THE SITUATION THAT IS
HAPPENING ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND MOST
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES- AND
WE NEED TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO CONNECT THE DOTS AND CONNECT
PEOPLE TO THE RESOURCES. THAT
ARE AVAILABLE BUT MAYBE NOT
AVAILABLE RIGHT AT THEIR
DISPOSAL TO SIMPLY BECAUSE IT'S
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT TO ACCESS.
AND SELF THANK YOU FOR THE WORK
THAT YOU DO AND TO EVERYONE OUT
THERE RIGHT NOW THAT'S-
KNOCKING ON DOORS THAT'S TRYING
TO GET RESOURCES AS TRYING TO.
EDUCATE OUR COMMUNITY IN TERMS
OF WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE TO RISK.
CARE AND TO TRUST ULTIMATELY
AMID COBIT- THAT THE VACCINE IS
FREE. IT IS SAFE. NO ONE IS
GOING TO ASK FOR YOUR LEGAL
STATUS. AND THAT ULTIMATELY
IT'LL HELP SAVE LIVES AND WE
KNOW THAT IT IS OUR COMMUNITY
THAT ARE SUFFERING THE MOST AND
WE NEED TO DO ABSOLUTELY
EVERYTHING WE CAN. TO ENSURE
THAT FAMILIES ARE SAFE THE
STUDENTS RETURN TO SCHOOL
SAFELY THAT THEY ARE IF YOU'RE
TWELVE AND OVER THE YOU CAN GET
THE VACCINE AS WELL- AND THAT
YOU KNOW WE NEED TO DO
EVERYTHING WE POSSIBLY CAN TO
ENSURE THAT. WE MOVE FORWARD IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU INTERNET COME AFTER
MYSTICAL THING THANK YOU THIS
AMERICAN DO A MENTION PROJECT
ONE CAN AS I JUST WANT TO
MENTION EXCITED I'M FLUID
UNIQUE AND I THINK OTHERS
MAYBE. IN SOME OF ITS RATIONS
BUT OVER THE YEARS. UNOCAL'S
GALLAGHER HOUSE MANY MANY MANY
FOSTER YOUTH. IN THE MOST
EXPENSIVE MARKET IN THE NATION.
AND I MENTION THAT BECAUSE YOU
KNOW WE ARE PUTTING THIS MONEY.
FROM YOU KNOW BEFORE HOUSING
HOUSING THE HOMELESS HOUSING
THOSE AT RISK OF HOMELESSNESS.
WHAT IS THE- BEST WAY. OR HOW
WOULD YOU FRAME- OUR- OUR ARM.
THE METHODOLOGY OF GETTING
RESOURCES DOWN THAT WOULD BE
MOST HELPFUL TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER. OF HOMES AND BUILDINGS.
ABLE TO GET AND CONVERT INTO
HOUSING. IT'S AMERICA I THINK
THAT'S A QUESTION I THINK THAT.
YOU KNOW THIS IS PROBABLY AND
YOU KNOW I MEAN I'VE BEEN DOING
THIS TWENTY YEARS IS PROBABLY
THE FIRST TIME IN A LESS.
PROBABLY FOR YEARS. THAT PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND FOSTER CARE BECAUSE
I TALKED TO HIM THROUGH THE
LENS OF HOUSING. EVERYONE
UNDERSTAND THERE'S A HOUSING
CRISIS WERE MEASURED YOUNG
PERSON IN FOSTER CARE. THAT-
DOESN'T HAVE A FAMILY SUPPORTS-
LEAST FOSTER CARE. DOES HAVE A
PLACE TO GO AND SO. THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LEVERAGE- YOU
KNOW OUR OUR DEVELOPERS. ARE A
FOUNDATION PARTNERS. ARE
GOVERNMENT PARTNERS AND OUR
CORPORATIONS TO COME TOGETHER
AND STRATEGIZE ON WAYS THAT WE
CAN CREATE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FOR YOUNG FOLKS AND- WE DID
THAT IN OUR PROJECT- PROJECT
SAFE IT WITH MID PENN WE GET
CARVE OUTS- IN MID PENN
COMMUNITIES FOR SET ASIDES-
CYST SPECIFICALLY FOR KIDS IN
FOSTER CARE. AND BEING ABLE TO
CHARGE THEM. WHAT I CALL WHAT
pWE WOULD DO A PHONE KIDS THEY
PAY FIVE HUNDRED BUCKS A MONTH
FOR FIVE YEARS. SO FROM AGE
TWENTY ONE TO TWENTY SIX. THEY
HAVE IT UP TO GIVE DEVELOPING
GROWING AND MATURING LIKE ALL
OF OUR YOUNG ADULTS DO THAT
THAT LEAVE OUR HOMES AS KIDS.
AND NOT HAVE THE BURDEN OF. THE
OR THE OR THE CRISIS OF THE
STRESS LEVEL OF NOT HAVING A
PLACE TO LIVE. BECAUSE FOR MANY
YOUNG FOLKS TO. THEY GO UP YOU
KNOW IN TWENTY DIFFERENT
ENVIRONMENTS TWENTY DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES GOING TO TWENTY
DIFFERENT SCHOOLS. FINALLY
GIVEN TO A PLACE OF STABILITY
IS A PLACE THAT THEY COULD FILL
HOPE AND THEREFORE WORK ON
THEIR- OWN SELF HELP AND WORK
ON THEIR EDUCATION GOING TO
SCHOOL. AND REALLY DEALING WITH
THE TRAUMAS OF REALLY GOING
THROUGH THAT SYSTEM BEING
SEPARATE FROM FAMILIES. THERE
ARE SOME GOOD MODELS OUT THERE
PROJECTS SAFE HAVEN SECONDLY
COMMITTEE FOUNDATION CAME UNDER
REPORT ON IT'S ON THE WEBSITE.
AND AGAIN IT LEVERAGES OUR
DEVELOPERS LEVERAGES OUR
NONPROFITS THAT LEVERAGES OUR
CORPORATE PARTNERS AND OUR CITY
COUNTY- PROVIDERS TO COME
TOGETHER AND REALLY DEVELOP A
STRATEGY. THAT WE CAN GIVE
FOLKS A COULD. ON HOUSING. EVEN
IN THE MOST X. MARKET RIGHT.
MARKET SOME YOU KNOW MANY OF US
HAVE YOUNG FOLKS WENT OFF TO
COLLEGE AND THEY'RE LIVING HERE
BECAUSE WE HELP THEM OUT. OUR
PHONES YOU DON'T HAVE THAT SO
THIS IS THE WAY. THE COMMUNITY
CAN WEIGH AND LEAD IN AND HELP
HELP- GIVE ACCESS AND THAT'S IF
YOU. HAVE BEEN PROJECT IN
PARTICULAR. THAT PROGRAM IS. A
CERTAIN FIXED NUMBER OF UNITS
IN A LARGER AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
DEVELOPMENT OR OR YEAH. I MEAN
ABSOLUTELY I THINK WHAT WE
ALWAYS LOOK AT IS WHEN YOU SEE
A YOUNG FOLKS OFF TO COLLEGE
LIVE IN THE DORMS. TWO YEARS AT
THAT THE TO GO LIVE IN SURE
HOMES AND EVENTUALLY GOT THEIR
OWN APARTMENTS- CREATING THAT
HOUSING CONTINUUM. AND
LEVERAGING DEVELOPERS TO SAY.
IN ANY NEW DEVELOPMENTS OR EVEN
EXISTED ONCE DOOR CARVE OUT
GIVE US TEN UNITS SET ASIDE.
SPECIFICALLY FOR KIDS IN FOSTER
CARE. AND LET US COME TOGETHER
AND PAY THAT RENT FOR THAT
YOUNG PERSON BE THERE FOR FIVE
YEARS. JUST AS WE WOULD DO FOR
YOUR SON OR DAUGHTER GOES OFF
TO COLLEGE IT IS A- GREAT MODEL
WE HAVE GREAT OUTCOMES ON THAT
MODEL AND WE'RE DEL SCALING
THAT- THROUGHOUT THE AREA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT
EXPLANATION THANK YOU. JUST ONE
PIECE I WOULD ADD IS THAT IT I
THINK SOMETIMES WE THINK ABOUT
THESE PROBLEMS IN ISOLATION OF
THE ALL OF THE OTHER ONES AND
SO A SUCCESSFUL HOUSING
STRATEGY HAS TO BE. AN
INTERSECTING STRATEGY AND SO WE
HAVE TO THINK ABOUT NOT JUST A
HOUSING PROBLEM IT'S AN
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT PROBLEM IS
AN EDUCATION. C. ISSUES IN THAT
INTERSECTION WE'RE NOT GOING TO
BE SUCCESSFUL IN ANY OF THEM ON
THEIR OWN. THANK YOU WE- I'LL
JUST ADD ONE MORE COMMENT ON
HOUSING AND SOMETHING THAT THE
STATE IS GOING TO FACE VERY
SOON AND I HOPE THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO ADDRESS IT IN IN BUDGET
NEXT YEAR MOVING FORWARD-
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE GOING TO
FACE IN LOS ANGELES VERY SOON
AS THE- AT THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING COVENANTS THAT. ARE SET
TO EXPIRE WITHIN FIFTY FIVE
YEARS WILL BE EXPIRING. VERY
SOON WITHIN THE NEXT FEW YEARS
WHICH IS GOING TO DISPLACE
FAMILIES IS GOING TO DISPLACE.
CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE. AND SO
WE NEED THE ADVOCACY WORK TO
ENSURE THAT. THE CUT THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING COVENANTS
ACROSS THE STATE AND
SPECIFICALLY IN AREAS- THAT ARE
HIGHLY EXPENSIVE LIKE THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES AND OTHER AREAS.
THAT WE MAINTAIN THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS AVAILABLE EVEN
THOUGH. WE'RE MOVING
LEGISLATION RIGHT NOW TO ENSURE
THAT. THE WOULD- MAKE IT
UNDERSTANDABLE FOR A LOCAL CITY
A LOCAL MUNICIPALITY TO EXPAND
BEYOND THE FIFTY FIVE YEARS
THAT ARE MANDATED BY THE STATE.
IF THEY WANT TO DO ONE HUNDRED
THEY ABSOLUTELY CAN. BUT FOR
THE ONES THAT ARE ALREADY
EXISTING THAT ARE EXPIRING.
YOUR ADVOCACY YOUR SUPPORT-
TOWARD THOSE THOSE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING COVENANTS THAT ARE SENT
TO BE EXPIRING WILL ALSO BE
INCREDIBLY HELPFUL. AND I WANT
TO THANK THE PANEL NUMBER TWO-
JUST BEEN VERY INFORMATIVE IT
WAS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION. NATURAL BRING A
PANEL NUMBER THREE STRATEGIC
INVESTMENTS IN CAREER PATHWAYS
IN GENERATIONAL WEALTH.
BUILDING AND BUY POT
COMMUNITIES. AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW. THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
PROVIDES MORE THAN ONE BILLION.
IT WOULD BE. FORCE PACIFIC
COOLEY FOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. IF AND IF WE ADD
THE FUNDS DIRECTED TO HIGHER
EDUCATION AND HEALTHCARE. THE
BUDGET INVEST MORE THAN FIVE
BILLION WITH A B. IN OUR
WORKERS AND LOCAL ECONOMY. BUT
WHAT DOES THIS MEAN FOR MEN
BOYS WOMEN OF COLOR WE KNOW
THAT EVEN WITH THIS STATE
INVESTMENT RELY ON INDUSTRY. TO
PROVIDE JOBS FOR PEOPLE TO
INVEST IN THEMSELVES AND THE
COMMUNITY. TO DATE WE'VE ASKED
OUR PANELISTS TO DISCUSS
INVESTMENT. IN MEANINGFUL
CAREER PATHWAYS FOR COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR AND HOW WE CAN TRULY
GENERATE. GENERATIONAL WEALTH-
SO WE LIKE TO CALL TERROR
GREAT. A DIRECTOR OFFICE OF
SMALL BUSINESS ADVOCATE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT-
CALLED KOBE IS. MARIA SALINAS
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER THE LOS
ANGELES AREA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE TRAINABILITY WAIVER
DIRECTOR CORPORATE SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY UNION BANK. BOYS
TO MEN OF COLOR CORPORATE
ADVISORY BOARD MEMBER. AND JEFF
WALLACE PRESIDENT AND CHIEF
EJECTED BOTHERS OFFICER LEADERS
UP. CHAU WHICHEVER READY
TERRORIST YOU WOULD YOU LIKE
BEGIN FIRST. ASSEMBLY MEMBER AT
JONES SAWYER AND MEMBERS OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE THANK YOU- FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY
AND FOR. THE PARTNERSHIPS THAT
HAVE BEEN FORMED. AND FOSTERED-
INCLUDING THE SUPPORT FOR THE
WORK BEING DONE BY MY OFFICE. I
AM CAROLYN CRAIG DIRECTOR OF
THE OFFICE OF THE SMALL
BUSINESS ADVOCATE PART OF THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE SAYS BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. MY
OFFICE SUPPORTS ECONOMIC GROWTH
AND INNOVATION AND ENSURES THAT
ALL CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESSES
ANDINNOVATIVE START UPS HAVE
THE INFORMATION AND DIRECT
SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED TO
BETTER NAVIGATE RESOURCES
PROGRAMS AND REGULATIONS.
CALAMOS BA'S SERVES AS THE
VOICE OF SMALL BUSINESS
REPRESENTING THEIR VIEWS AND
INTERESTS ACROSS THE STATE AND
ADVOCATING FOR EQUITABLE ACCESS
TO CAPITAL MARKETS AND NETWORKS
SO THAT ALL. CALIFORNIA SMALL
BUSINESSES SUCCESSFULLY START
MANAGE GROW AND BECOME MORE
RESILIENT ACT. WHEN LOOKING AT
OUR CHALLENGES FACING BOYS AND
MEN OF COLOR ARMY IN WEALTH
BUILDING AND PROSPERITY I CAN
THINK OF SEVERAL IMPEDIMENTS TO
SUCCESS MANY WE HEARD ON
EARLIER AND PANELS I'M I THINK
OF CAREER PATHWAYS WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. ENTREPRENEURSHIP
EDUCATION AND I SEE NATURAL
INTERSECTIONS BETWEEN
UNDERSERVED YOUTH AND THE WORK
OF MY OFFICE AND OTHER OFFICES
WITH AND THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES I'M FACING POISONED
AND THAT MEN OF COLOR STEM FROM
ECONOMIC CHALLENGES IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND LACK OF
INVESTMENT FOR YEARS PRIOR TO
THIS ADMINISTRATION. THE
PANDEMIC INDUCED ECONOMIC
HARDSHIPS THAT WE'VE EXPERIENCE
HAVE EXACERBATED THOSE ISSUES
WITH MANY- BUSINESSES CLOSING
THEIR DOORS AND ROUGHLY 40% OF
BLACK AND WHITE NEXT BUSINESSES
CLOSED. THE GOOD NEWS ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE SEEN IT
IS STARTER LEADERSHIP- BOTH IN
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE CREATED ACCESS
TO PROGRAMS RESOURCES AND
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES TO HELP WITH
ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND MAKE AN
IMPACT ON SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES FACING BOYS AND MEN
OF COLOR. FOR EXAMPLE I MY
OFFICE IS ADMINISTERING- THE
LARGEST SMALL BUSINESS FOCUSED
BUDGET IN THE HISTORY OF THE
DEPARTMENT FOR BILLION IN COULD
BE NINETEEN RELIEF FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES FIFTY MILLION IN
RELIEF FOR MICRO BUSINESSES
WHICH IS THE SMALLEST OF SMALL
BUSINESSES WITH LESS THAN FIVE
EMPLOYEES AND UNDER FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN. ANNUAL
REVENUE THESE MICRO BUSINESSES.
ARE PREDOMINANTLY OWNED BY
PEOPLE OF. GETTING ASSISTANCE
TO STAY OPEN REOPEN IT AND EVEN
RETOOL HOPES THE SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS IN OUR ECONOMY CREATE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SOMEONE ELSE
AND BY THAT I MEAN JOBS SMALL
BUSINESSES EMPLOY TWO THIRDS OF
THE WORK FORCE AND SMALL
BUSINESSES OWNED BY PEOPLE OF
COLOR. EMPLOY PEOPLE OF COLOR
THAT TRANSLATES TO OPPORTUNITY
FOR BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR YOUNG
ADULTS EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR
MEET THESE OPPORTUNITIES TO
GAIN VALUABLE WORK EXPERIENCE
AND SKILLS. DUE TO A IO'S
TAPESTRY REPORTS ARE PUBLISHED
A FEW YEARS AGO FOR PEOPLE OF
COLOR ENTREPRENEURSHIP IS THE
FASTEST WAY TO BUILD WEALTH
BLACK ENTREPRENEURS FOR EXAMPLE
ARE WEALTHIER THAN THEIR NON
ENTREPRENEURIAL COUNTERPARTS
SILVA KEYED TO BUILDING WEALTH
FOR BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR IS TO
BUILD BUSINESSES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. AND THAT
REQUIRES SUPPORT FOR
ENTREPRENEURSHIP THAT IS
INCLUSIVE AND FOCUSED ON
UNDERSERVED GROUPS WE'VE SEEN
THIS PAST YEAR EXACTLY HOW
POWERFUL OUR SMALL BUSINESS
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE NETWORK IS
THEY INCREASE THEIR INTAKE WITH
SMALL BUSINESSES AND MORE THAN
FIVE HUNDRED PARTNERS PROVIDED
SUPPORT FOR SMALL BUSINESSES
APPLYING FOR REEF RELIEF GRANT
MONIES. IN THIRTEEN DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES WE NOW HAVE THE
INTEGRATED AND COORDINATED
BACKBONE TO CONTINUE THINKING
INCLUSIVELY AND DELIVERING
SUPPORT AS OUR ECONOMY BUILDS
BACK BETTER WITH EVEN GREATER
SMALL BUSINESS CAPACITY AND
GROWTH ACROSS THE STATE. AS WE
CONTINUED TO FUND THAT NETWORK
WE CAN EXPECT TO SEE CONTINUED
GROWTH AND DEVELOPMENT OF ALL
SMALL BUSINESSES INCLUDING
FOUNDERS OF COLOR. ADDITIONALLY
THE NEW CALIFORNIA DREAM FUND
WHICH IS A SMALL BUSINESS START
UP GRANT PROGRAM THAT WILL MAKE
UP TO TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
AVAILABLE TO SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS THAT HAVE COMPLETED AND
APPROVED ENTREPRENEURIAL SMALL
BUSINESS EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM IS
THE PATHWAY TO OPPORTUNITY AND
WEALTH BUILDING IN COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR. ARE I HAD PROGRAM
WHICH WE HAVE PLANNED TO RE
LAUNCH- THAT WITH A TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
IN INCLUSIVE INNOVATION HUBS.
IS DESIGNED TO AND SO SENATE
VICE INCLUSIVE DIVERSE AND
EQUITABLE INNOVATION ACTIVITIES
IN THE STATE'S TECH AND SCIENCE
BASED START UP ECOSYSTEM
THEREBY BUILDING THE OVERALL
CAPACITY FOR INNOVATION ACROSS
THE STATE. WITH SERVICES FOR
FOUNDERS OF COLOR. ADDITIONALLY
WE ARE ADMINISTERING A
NONPROFIT PERFORMING ARTS
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT GRANT AND
THIS PROGRAM IS DESIGNED TO
HELP CREATE WORKFORCE
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE ARTS
THROUGH A FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT SO THESE ARE SOME OF
THE RESOURCES AVAILABLE THROUGH
MY OFFICE ON THE IN ADDITION
THERE ARE OTHER. RESOURCES AND
PROGRAMS THROUGH COBIZ THE
COMMUNITY AND REINVESTMENT
GRANT CANNABIS EQUITY PROGRAM I
THINK SMALL BUSINESS FINANCE
CENTER AND I THINK DISASTER
RELIEF LOAN GUARANTEE PROGRAM
AND OF COURSE THE CALIFORNIA
REBUILDING FIND SO FROM MY
VANTAGE POINT AS OUR DIRECTOR
OF CALLAWAY'S BA I SEE ALL OF
THESE RESOURCES AND SUPPORT FOR
ENTREPRENEURSHIP WORKING
TOGETHER TO CREATE THREE
DISTINCT THREE DISTINCT AREAS
OF IMPACT FOR BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR. THE FIRST ERROR YET OF
IMPACT IS REALLY UPSCALE.
UPSKILLING EXCUSE ME. AND-
UPSKILLING ARE YOU ARE YOU ANY
INCREASING CAREER PATHWAYS
THROUGH WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES AND EMERGING AND
REVITALIZING INDUSTRIES WHICH
IS POSSIBLE THROUGH
PARTNERSHIPS WITH SMALL
BUSINESSES WHO CREATE
INTERNSHIP JOBS AND OPPORTUNITY
FOR UNDERSERVED YOUTH SECOND AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RECLAIM NATURAL
HUMAN RESOURCES WHICH HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY THE JUSTICE SYSTEM
WITH A FOCUS ON IT RE ENTRY ON
THE NORTH'S. THIRD AN
OPPORTUNITYTO CREATE SYSTEMIC
ECONOMIC MOBILITY WHICH
UTILIZES EXISTING PROGRAMS TO
DEAL WITH BARRIERS TO FINANCIAL
SUCCESS THERE ARE OFTEN
EXPERIENCE BY UNDERSERVED
GROUPS DID IT ZIP CODE RACE AND
GENDER DISPARITIES THAT TO YOU
THIS MORNING UNTIL- SO THIS
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS AND- IF
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER. JONES
SAWYER AND MEMBERS OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON
ENTREPRENEURSHIP TODAY THANK
YOU IN A MOMENT THANKS TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE SHOULD
LOOKING AT MICHAEL BUSINESSES
AND I ALSO WANT TO. BRING
REALLY SALINAS THE CHIEFS
ACROSS OF LOS ANGELES AREA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT I PUBLICLY
THANK YOU FOR WHEN DURING THE
PANDEMIC WHAT I BROUGHT TO YOU
THAT MICROCASSETTE SIS- STREET
VENDORS IMMIGRANT VENDORS. YOU
GOT IT. YOU UNDERSTOOD IT HE
UNDERSTOOD WHY- WHILE THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA MY ALMA MATER MAY BE
THE LARGEST SINGLE EMPLOYER.
THE MICRO BUSINESSES ARE THE
LARGEST EMPLOYERS IN MY
DISTRICT AND SELECTED THANK YOU
FOR MAKING SURE THAT THE
CHAMBER. TOOK CARE THEM TOO
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE BIG
LOBBYISTS AND PEOPLE COME UP
HERE TO SPEAK ON YOUR BEHALF
SO. SO THANK YOU FOR PROTECTING
THEM GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
FOR THOSE COMMENTS AND YOU'LL
SEE THAT- I WILL MAKE REFERENCE
TO THAT AS WELL BECAUSE I DO
BELIEVE THAT IS AN IMPORTANT
PART. OF OUR ECONOMY AND LOS
ANGELES THE CAN NOT BE X. FROM.
ANYTHING WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HERE TODAY- BUT GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE MY NAME IS MARIA
SALINAS I AM THE PRESIDENT AND
CEO OF THE LOS ANGELES AREA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. THANK YOU
FOR THE INVITATION TO JOIN THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON THE STATUS
OF BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR- MORE
IMPORTANTLY I'M THE MOTHER OF
FOUR BOYS SO THIS TOPIC IS VERY
MUCH NEAR AND DEAR TO MY HEART.
KNOWING THAT MY OWN CHILDREN
AND WHAT I'VE BEEN ABLE TO
IMPART ON THEM. THROUGH MY
LEARNING- HAS HELPED THEM MAKE
IT ON THEIR WAY I THINK OF
THOSE YOUNG MEN AND BOYS THAT-
DON'T HAVE MAYBE THAT PARENTAL
SUPPORT AND NEED THE GUIDANCE
SO THANK YOU FOR CONVENING US
TODAY. THE CHAMBER REPRESENTS
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY THAT
SUPPORTS THE REGIONAL ECONOMY
AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
pCONSISTING OF FIVE NEIGHBORING
COUNTIES LA ORANGE COUNTY
VENTURA SAN BERNARDINO AND
RIVERSIDE. YOU ALL KNOW THAT
LOS ANGELES IS A VERY DYNAMIC
ECONOMY THAT RECEIVED THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF LARGE AND
SMALL BUSINESSES AND MICRO
ENTERPRISES ALIKE. THE CHAMBER
IS FOCUSED FOR MANY YEARS NOT
ONLY ON ENSURING THE GROWTH OF
THIS ECONOMY. BUT ALSO ENSURING
THAT WE HAVE AN EQUITABLE
ECONOMY AND THAT IT'S AN
INCLUSIVE ECONOMY. WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE SMALLEST OF
ENTERPRISES THE MICRO
ENTERPRISES EQUALLY CONTRIBUTE
TO THE DYNAMICS NOTICES SOME OF
THIS REGION. WE KNOW THAT WE
HAVE THE LARGEST CONCENTRATION
OF MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES IN
THE COUNTRY. IN FACT IN LA
COUNTY ALONE 93% OF BUSINESSES
HAVE LESS THAN TWENTY
EMPLOYEES. AND WE KNOW THAT
MANY OF THOSE BUSINESSES ARE
RUN BY BUSINESS OWNERS THAT
ARMED MEN OF COLOR. THE LA
CHAMBER IS FOCUSED NOT ONLY ON
THE PUBLIC POLICY THAT WILL
SUPPORT THEIR BUSINESS GROWTH
AND THEY'RE ON TO PUSH YOUR
DREAMS. BUT IT HELPS BUILD OUT
AN INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS
NEEDED SO THAT THESE DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING THE BOYS
AND MEN AND- AND MEN OF COLOR
ARE INCLUDED IN THIS NEW
ECONOMY THAT IS GROWING. WE
LEVERAGE MUCH OF THE RESOURCES
THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO THIS ODD
TO US THROUGH THE STATE MANY
THAT WERE JUST SO ELOQUENTLY
DESCRIBED BY MR LYNN GRAY. IT
IS REALLY WITH THEIR
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE STATE WITH
GO BIZ AND THAT- OFFICE OF THE
SMALL BUSINESS ADVOCATE THAT WE
CAN PARTNER COLLABORATE AND
REALLY ACHIEVE SOME REALLY
GREAT OUTCOMES SO I DO NOT WANT
IT- LEFT GOING ON WITHOUT
SAYING THAT THAT PARTNERSHIP IS
KEY TO THE LOS ANGELES AREA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT ENTREPRENEURSHIP.
WE KNOW THAT PERSONS OF COLOR
ARE INCREDIBLY ENTREPRENEURIAL
AND WHY IS THAT. IS BECAUSE
MANY TIMES THEY ARE FACING
SYSTEMIC BARRIERS IN NORMAL
EMPLOYMENT. AND THEY ARE VERY
RESOURCES FULL AND ARE LOOKING
FOR THEIR WAY TO MAKE ENDS MEET
AND MANY TIMES THAT MEANS AND
STARTING THEIR OWN BUSINESS. IN
RECOGNIZING THAT WE KNOW AT THE
LA CHAMBER THAT IT IS IMPORTANT
TO CHAMPION ON ENTREPRENEURSHIP
AS A MEANS OF ECONOMIC MOBILITY.
WE KNOW THAT IT MEANS THAT WE
SHOULD BE SUPPORTING AND DO
SUPPORT WORK PAID WORK BASED
LEARNING INITIATIVES. TO ENSURE
THAT BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR
UNDERSTAND THE CAREER OPTIONS
THE CAREER PATHWAYS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO THEM. THE CHAMBER
HAS A LONG HISTORY OF
CHAMPIONING AN INCLUSIVE AN
ECONOMY AND ONES THAT WORKS-
WITH PARTNERING WITH OUR
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS IN
FACT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THE
L. A. CHAMBER WORKS VERY
CLOSELY IS WITH OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT. IN LA ALONE
THERE ARE NINE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THAT FOCUS ON VARIOUS
TRADES AND SKILLS WE BRING THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY WE PARTNER
WITH OUR EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM AND
TOGETHER WE BELIEVE THAT WE CAN
YIELD AN OUTCOME OF BRINGING-
BRINGING THAT THE FUTURE WORK
FORCE ALONG WITH THE TRAITS AND
SKILLS THAT ARE KEY AND
IMPORTANT TO OUR ECONOMY. IT IS
OUR GOAL TO ENSURE THAT LARGE
AND SMALL EMPLOYERS FROM THIS
REGION HAVE THAT TALENT THAT IS
NEEDED TO CONTINUE TO INNOVATE
AND CREATE JOBS. THE FUTURE IS
ABOUT INNOVATION THE FUTURE IS
ABOUT JOB CREATION. AND AS WE
EMERGE FROM THIS PANDEMIC WE
KNOW THAT OUR ECONOMY WILL GROW
SO WILL BE IMPORTANT FOR US IS
TO ANSWER THE QUESTION WILL WE
INCLUDE EVERYONE. WILL THIS BE
AN INCLUSIVE ECONOMY AS WE
EMERGE FROM THIS PANDEMIC
THAT'S THE CHALLENGE FOR ALL OF
US THAT'S WHAT WE MUST FIGURE
OUT TO ENSURE THAT BOYS AND MEN
OF COLOR. THAT ALL THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE REPRESENTED THROUGHOUT
OUR GREAT STATE CAN PARTICIPATE
IN THE FUTURE GROWTH OF THIS
ECONOMY. THE CHAMBER HAS TWO
PROGRAMS IN PARTICULAR THAT I
WANTED TO MENTION THAT WE CALL
THEM PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS THAT HELP CREATE
CAREER PATHWAYS. ONE IS THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
BUSINESS OWNERS. WHO RECEIVE
MENTORSHIP TRAINING AND MATCH
MAKING OPPORTUNITY FOR THEIR
BUSINESSES TO ENSURE THAT THEY
CAN CONTINUE TO GROW. MANY OF
TIMES IT RELATES TO THE
CONTRACTING OPPORTUNITIES. THE
STATE LAUNCHED AN INITIATIVE OF
SOURCE LOCAL SOURCE DIVERSE WE
ARE THE BIGGEST ADVOCATES FOR
THAT PROGRAM. BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE THAT OF LARGE
ORGANIZATIONS WHO ARE
PURCHASING THAT THROUGH THEIR
OWN PURCHASING POWER. THEY CAN-
IMPACT THOSE SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT NEED THAT ECONOMIC GROWTH
BY AWARDING A CONTRACT WORKING
WITH THE- GOBIZ OFFICE AND THE
OFFICE OF THE SMALL BUSINESS
ADVOCATE. WE ARE THRILLED THAT
WE ARE DOING MORE AND MORE IN
THIS SPACE. THIS IS SOMETHING
WHERE WE SPECIFICALLY TARGET-
PERSONS OF COLOR TO GO THROUGH
THIS TRAINING. TO ENSURE THAT
THEY ARE UNDERSTANDING THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE NEEDED BY
THE STATE AND OTHER PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE AGENCIES. TO BE ABLE TO
GROW THEIR BUSINESS TO BE ABLE
TO GROW THEIR DREAMS OF BEING
AN ENTREPRENEUR. I I THINK THAT
PROGRAM IS SOMETHING THAT IS
AVAILABLE AND SHOULD BE TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF IN A MUCH LONGER
WAY LARGER WAY. THE SECOND
PROGRAM I WANTED TO TALK ABOUT
WAS THE CAREER PATHWAYS WORK
THAT THE LA CHAMBER HAS DONE-
MANY OF YOU THAT I WORK WITH
THE ALI CHAMBER KNOW THAT FOR
MANY YEARS WE HAVE A DEEP-
EXPERIENCE IN CRADLE TO CAREER
INITIATIVE. IN PARTICULAR FOR
CAREER PATHWAYS WE WORK WITH
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES AND L.
A. COUNTY. IN ENSURING THAT WE
CAN CONNECT STUDENTS FROM
UNDERREPRESENTED COMMUNITIES TO
INTERNSHIP OPPORTUNITIES
APPRENTICESHIPS. WITH START UPS
OR WITH LARGE ORGANIZATIONS.
THE BENEFIT TO PROGRAMS LIKE
THIS IS NOT ONLY OUR STUDENTS
PROVIDED THE INSIDE OF VARIOUS
CAREER PATHS AND CAREER
OPPORTUNITIES. BUT FOR THOSE
LARGER ORGANIZATIONS THEY ARE
TAPPING INTO A DIVERSE WORK
FORCE SOMETHING THAT THEY
HIGHLY NEED NOW AND THERE IS A
GREATER ATTENTION TO THAT THAT
WE SEE TODAY. FOR THIS REASON
LAST YEAR THE CHAMBER SUPPORTED
PROPOSITION SIXTEEN THE REPEAL
OF PROP TWO OH NINE WHICH
HAPPENED CHAMPIONED
OPPORTUNITIES TO CREATE MORE
EQUITABLE ACCESS. TO JOBS TO
VARIOUS- PROGRAMS FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. SOME OF
OUR LARGER MEMBERS HAVE ALSO
INITIATED PROGRAMS FOR EXAMPLE
JPMORGAN CHASE A MEMBER OF THE
CHAMBER OFFERS FELLOWSHIP INTER
INITIATIVE PROGRAM THAT WAS
LAUNCHED IN TWENTY TEN. THIS
FELLOWSHIP HAS PREPARED YOUNG
MEN OF COLOR FOR THE FUTURE
WORKFORCE THROUGH INCREASED
ACCESS AND MENTORSHIP AND
PREPAREDNESS AND CAREER
READINESS WE ARE SEEING MORE
AND MORE OF LARGER
ORGANIZATIONS TAKING IT UPON
THEMSELVES TO HELP CREATE THE
WORK FORCE THAT THEY ARE
LOOKING FOR IN THE FUTURE. THE
ESTABLISHMENT AND THE
CONTINUATION OF PROGRAMS SUCH
AS THE USE THAT I HAVE
MENTIONED TO ME ARE THE COLOR
CORNERSTONE OF ECONOMIC
RECOVERY. ENTREPRENEURSHIP
MEANS ECONOMIC MOBILITY.
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT MEANS
THAT OUR FUTURE TALENT WILL
HAVE A PLACE TO LIVE AND GROW
AND ENSURE THAT THEY'RE WORKING.
OUR GOAL IS TO PUT THE LOS
ANGELES REGION AS WELL AS
CALIFORNIA ON A PATH TOWARDS
TRUE EQUAL OPPORTUNITY AND
ACCESS FOR ALL. THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE I LOOK FORWARD
TO TAKING ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ANNEXURE
BRING UP BETWEEN OPINION WAIVER
DIRECTOR CORPORATE
RESPONSIBILITY UNION BANK. GOOD
AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN JONES SAWYER
FOR INVITING ME TODAY TO JOIN
THIS PANEL ON CAREER PATHWAYS
AND WEALTH BUILDING FOR BOYS
AND MEN OF COLOR. IT'S AN HONOR
FOR ME TO REPRESENT MUFG UNION
BANK AND THIS SELECT COMMITTEES
CORPORATE ADVISORY BOARD. I AM
A MOM OF TWO MAKES THE PAIN OF
BOYS MYSELF I THOUGHT I WOULD
ADD THAT AS PART OF THE REASON
WHY I'M SO PASSIONATE ABOUT
THIS ISSUE- AGAIN I'M TRYING OF
THE END OF A WITH MUFG UNION
BANK AND I AM PART OF THE-
BANK'S CORPORATE SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY TEAM. I HAVE
BEEN AT THE BANK FOR ALMOST TEN
YEARS AND HAVE HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF BEING AT AN
INSTITUTION. WHERE CSR IS
DEEPLY INGRAINED IN EVERY
ASPECT OF OUR BUSINESS. IN FACT
JUST THIS WEEK THE PUBLICATION
THE AMERICAN BANKER. EXCUSE ME-
RELEASED A REPORT ON THE
FINANCIAL SERVICES COMPANIES
CUSTOMERS MOST ADMIRE AND I'M
PROUD TO SAY THAT UNION BANK
WAS RANKED NUMBER FOUR.
ACCORDING TO THE SURVEY
CONDUCTED BY THE AMERICAN
BANKER UNION BANK RATED HIGH
WITH CUSTOMERS NOT JUST FOR ITS
SOPHISTICATED PRODUCT OFFERINGS
BUT ALSO FOR ITS ETHICAL
BUSINESS PRACTICES AND FOR
BEING A POSITIVE FORCE IN THE
COMMUNITIES IT SERVES. THE
CHALLENGES OF THE PAST YEAR AND
A HALF I MADE- THREE PRIORITIES
CRYSTAL CLEAR FOR US AS THE
FINANCIAL INSTITUTION FIRST WE
NEED TO SUPPORT OUR CLIENTS
DURING UNPREDICTABLE ECONOMIC
SHIFTS. SECOND WE NEED TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT TO OUR
COMMUNITIES WITH THE RESOURCES
TO WEATHER THE FINANCIAL
DOWNTURN. AND THIRD ENSURING
THAT OUR COLLEAGUES ARE SAFE
AND SUPPORTED. WHILE OUR CSR
WORK IS GROUNDED IN THE
COMMUNITY REINVESTMENT ACT OR
CRA WE BELIEVE IN HAVING A
DEEPER UNDERSTANDING OF THE
COMMUNITIES WE SERVE.
PARTNERING WITH LOCAL COMMUNITY
AND GOVERNMENT LEADERS AND
PROVIDING THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO ACHIEVE THEIR
GOALS. TO QUOTE JULIUS ROBINSON
OUR HEAD OF CORPORATE SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY WE UNDERSTAND
HOW INTRINSICALLY RACIAL
INEQUITIES ARE INTERTWINED WITH
DISPARATE WEALTH DISTRIBUTION
IN AMERICA. IN JUNE TWENTY
TWENTY WE TOOK A SIGNIFICANT
STEP. USING REVENUE GENERATED
FROM THE PAYCHECK PROTECTION
PROGRAM WE CREATED A COMMUNITY
RECOVERY PROGRAM. A TEN MILLION
DOLLAR INITIATIVE TO SUPPORT
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS THAT
ARE DEDICATED TO SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC JUSTICE WITHIN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. THIS
PROGRAM WAS CREATED TO RESPOND
TO THE SHIFTING NEEDS OF OUR
WORLD. WE HAVE THE TOOLS TO
ADVANCE ECONOMIC INCLUSION IN
OUR COMMUNITIES AND IT'S CLEAR
THAT COMMUNITIES OF COLOR ARE
FACING AN UPHILL BATTLE TO
RECOVER FROM THIS PANDEMIC. SO
OUR GRANTS ARE C. R. P. GRANTS
ARE DIRECTED TO ORGANIZATIONS
AND PROGRAMS THAT FOCUS ON
SMALL BUSINESS RECOVERY
REBUILDING THE WORK FORCE AND
INCREASING FINANCIAL SECURITY.
WE ARE ALSO SUPPORTING
ORGANIZATIONS ADDRESSING
DISCRIMINATION INCLUDING ANTI
ASIAN HATE. SO FAR WE HAVE
PROVIDED OVER FOUR MILLION TO
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS. AS
PART OF OUR COMMITMENT TO
ECONOMIC INCLUSION WE PROMOTE
FINANCIAL EDUCATION THROUGH OUR
STUDENT RUN BRANCHES. EACH YEAR
TEN TO TWELVE STUDENTS AT FIVE
HIGH SCHOOLS. ARE SELECTED FOR
A YEAR LONG INTERNSHIP TO WORK
IN A BANK BRANCH LOCATED INSIDE
THEIR HIGH SCHOOL. A STUDENT
BANKERS THEIR- AND PRACTICE
CUSTOMER SERVICE SKILLS AND
EDUCATE CLASSMATES TEACHERS AND
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY ABOUT THE
BASICS OF PERSONAL FINANCE. THE
FIVE SCHOOLS ARE MCLEAN HIGH
SCHOOL IN FRESNO. CRENSHAW HIGH
HIMSELF DELHI. LINCOLN HIGHWAY
IN EAST DELHI LARA HIGH SCHOOL
IN ANAHEIM AND MOUNTAIN VIEW
HIGH IN EL MONTE. OVER THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY STUDENTS HAVE
GRADUATED FROM THE PROGRAM A
MAJORITY OF WHOM ARE STUDENTS
OF COLOR. OF WHICH 95% OF THEM
HAVE GONE ON TO COLLEGE. FORTY
ONE OF THE GRADUATES HAVE
BECOME BANK EMPLOYEES. AND OF
THE FORTY ONE FIVE OF US ENDED
TO OFFICER POSITIONS. MANY
OTHERS HAVE FOUND JOBS AT OTHER
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS. I'M
EXCITED TO SHARE THAT WE WILL
SOON BE OPENING OUR STUDENT RUN
BRANCH AT LANEY COLLEGE IN
OAKLAND. THIS WILL BE THE FIRST
STUDENT RUN BRANCH AT A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. THE BRANCH
IS CURRENTLY UNDER CONSTRUCTION
AND WILL BE OPEN TO THE PUBLIC
WHEN SCHOOL RESUMES IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION IN JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY TWO SORRY. TWO
YEARS AGO I JOIN THE CORPORATE
ADVISORY BOARD OF THIS SELECT
COMMITTEE. ADDRESSING THE NEEDS
OF BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR IS KEY
TO DEALING WITH RACIAL INEQUITY.
THE CAB INCLUDES ABOUT FIFTY
CORPORATIONS REPRESENTING
DIFFERENT INDUSTRIES INCLUDING
NORTHROP GRUMMAN. COCA COLA
AMAZON THE CREATIVE ARTISTS
AGENCY- FULL FACTORY. AND MOST
OF ALL MOST OF THE PROFESSIONAL
SPORTS ORGANIZATIONS IN THE
STATE INCLUDING THE SACRAMENTO
KINGS THE OAKLAND A.'S AND THE
LA RAMS. OUR PRIMARY OBJECTIVE
IS TO IDENTIFY AND DEVELOP
MEANINGFUL SOLUTIONS TO
INCREASE CAREER OPPORTUNITIES
FOR BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR IN
CALIFORNIA. OVER THE PAST TWO
YEARS WE HAVE DISCUSSED WHAT
ARE COMPANIES ARE ALREADY DOING.
TO CREATE A PIPELINE AND CAREER
PATHWAYS TO EXAMINE OUR OWN
HIRING AND RETENTION
PRIORITIES. WHAT DO WE OFFER IN
TERMS OF WORK BASED LEARNING IN
INTERNSHIPS AND HOW CAN WE
PROMOTE PUBLIC PRIVATE AND
NONPROFIT PARTNERSHIPS. MANY
CORPORATIONS ARE ON THE TABLE
ALREADY HAVE INITIATIVE TO
TACKLE THESE PRIORITIES AND WE
WANT THEM TO SHARE IT WITH THE
OTHERS. AS A CAB WE WANT A
SPECTRUM OF CAREER
OPPORTUNITIES FOR BOYS AND MEN
OF COLOR WE GUARD LIST OF THEIR
EDUCATIONAL LEVEL. WE WANT THEM
TO KNOW HOW THEY CAN BE
PROMOTED WE WANT THEM TO
INCREASE THEIR PAY IF THEY'RE
ALREADY WORKING IN A
CORPORATION. WE SHOULD FIGURE
OUT HOW TO WORK WITH ONE AND
THAT ONE ONE ANOTHER AND
PARTNER FOR EXAMPLE. AS A
FINANCIAL INSTITUTION HOW CAN
WE PARTNER TO PROVIDE FINANCIAL
EDUCATION TO ENCOURAGE HOME
OWNERSHIP AND OTHER WEALTH
BUILDING OPPORTUNITIES. WE
SHOULD WORK WITH NONPROFIT
PARTNERS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
TO PREPARE YOUNG MAN FOR
INTERNSHIP OPPORTUNITIES. THE
PANDEMIC A SLOW DOWN THE CAP A
BIT IN THE LAST YEAR BUT WE ARE
READY TO TACKLE THESE ISSUES.
SIDE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY AND I WANNA TURN IT OVER
TO THE NEXT SPEAKER JEFFREY
WALLACE FROM LEADERS UP THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
SEE ON THE SCREEN OR IS HE- I
DON'T SEE HIM HERE IN THE ROOM.
OKAY. WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
MISTER WALLACE.
WE'RE WORKING
ON IT. V. EXPERIENCING SOME
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES.
WE NEED
A LOT MORE TIME TO TRY TO GET
AMEND. YOU CAN SEE OVER HERE-
RIGHT NOW THEY'RE SAYING THEY
CAN'T SEE HIM BUT THEY CAN'T
HEAR HIM.
IF YOU WERE TRYING TO
DIAL IN ONE WEEK MAYBE DO SOME
QUESTION AND ANSWERS IN AND YOU
CAN DIAL IN. LET'S GO TO
QUESTION ANSWER WE DON'T. EIGHT
THERE'S ALREADY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHILE WE WAIT
TO SEE IF WE CAN GET MR
WALLACE'S. THANK YOU OR MISTER
SHARON THANK YOU TO THE
PRESENTER SO I'LL JUST SAY-
ESPECIALLY COMING FROM. SILICON
VALLEY IN THE FACT THAT- WE'RE
TALKING THE CAREER PATHWAYS
AND- CREATING GENERATIONAL
WEALTH AND I AGREE WITH THE
COMMENTS REGARDING
APPRENTICESHIPS AND- INTERNSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES WHAT HAVE YOU BUT
I THINK THAT- I'VE I'VE HEARD A
LOT ABOUT THAT OVER THE HERE'S-
AND I MEAN OVER THE DECADES-
AND THE DATA CONTINUES TO SHOW.
THAT THAT PEOPLE OF COLOR
PARTICULARLY BLACK LATINO
ENGINEERS ALL THE WAY DOWN TO.
EVERY LEVEL OF THE CORPORATE
AND ECONOMIC STRUCTURE OF THESE
COMPANIES THAT ARE PROFITING
WILDLY- THEIR NUMBER NUMBERS ON
THERE AND THE NUMBERS ARE THERE
WAS LIMITED TO IN THE COLOR. SO
THERE'S THE TELL ME THERE'S THE
SHOW ME AND THE REALITY IS THAT
WHAT IS BEING SHOWN IS THAT.
THAT THE HIRING IS NOT
HAPPENING AND WE HAVE. A BILL
WELL INTENTIONED WEATHER'S
LEGISLATORS WERE. PARTNERS IN
THE COMMUNITY THAT. EVERY YEAR
EVERY COUPLE YEARS COME BECAUSE
COMMUNITY MORE MORE PROGRAMS ON
THE OTHER AT THE END OF THE DAY
IS THE HIRING PRACTICES THAT
ARE NOT REFLECTING THE DESIRE
FOR THAT CHANGE- AND THAT GOES
TO ACCOUNTABILITY IN THE
REALITY IS THAT THE AMOUNT THAT
CAN'T FORCE PEOPLE TO HOP TO IT
TO HIRE FOLKS. BUT ONE OF THE
FEW THINGS WE CAN DO IS HOW
TRANSPARENCY. AND TIME AND
AGAIN- EFFORTS TO TRY TO GET
DATA ON HIRING- IS NOT
SUCCESSFUL AT LEAST NOT TO THE
EXTENT AS NECESSARY TO CREATE
REAL CHANGE- I HAVE HAD A BILL
THAT. I'M TRYING TO DO THAT
THIS PAST YEAR IT WAS NOT
SOMETHING WENT THROUGH OF THE
NUMBER OF THEM OVER THE YEARS.
AND SO YOU KNOW UNLESS- WERE
ABLE TO GET REAL DATA ON HIRING
PRACTICES ON DISCREPANCIES
APPEAR BETWEEN MEN AND WOMEN ON
DISCREPANCIES A PAY- BUT A BIT
BETWEEN- YOU KNOW FOR PEOPLE OF
COLOR- IT WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
ABLE TO. MAKE MEANINGFUL CHANGE
IN MY OPINION BECAUSE- IS THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY IS THAT
TRANSPARENCY. LEADS BROTHERS TO
SHAMING OR THROUGH THE PATS ON
THE BACK. THAT LEADS TO THE
POSITIVE MOVEMENT IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION SO. I GOTTA GET OUT
HERE BUT I THAT'S NOT MY LAST
COMMENT BECAUSE- I THINK- YOU
KNOW BUT WE- HEAR A LOT ABOUT.
STEM PROGRAMS AND INTERNSHIP AT
THE END OF THE DAY THE NUMBERS
ARE NOT THERE. AND THEY HAVEN'T
BEEN THERE FOR. MANY MERRILEES
CERTAINLY NOT TO THE EXTENT
THAT THE ENERGY PUT INTO IT SO
THOSE ARE THOSE ARE MY THOUGHTS
I DO APPRECIATE. EVERYTHING
THAT OUR PRESENTERS OF. HAVE
DEMONSTRATED AS THEIR DESIRE
WHAT THEY LIKE. TO SEE- BECAUSE
I'M WITH YOU. THANK YOU DID.
DID YOU WANT TO MAKE ANY
COMMENTS ARE SURE SURE ANOTHER
THE- IN THE STATE GO FROM THERE
YES NO I'M HAPPY I'M HAPPY TO-
TO MAKE SOME COMMENTS ON ON ON
THAT BECAUSE I THINK YOU'RE-
YOU'RE RIGHT OUR NUMBERS ARE
NOT THERE I WILL SAY. THAT I
BELIEVE THAT- SO WE'RE IN A
DIFFERENT TIME RIGHT NOW AND I
THINK YOU KNOW- THE PANDEMIC
WITHOUT A DOUBT YOU KNOW OPENED
A LOT OF EYES AROUND THE
DISPARITIES- I THINK ONE OF THE
COMMENTS THAT WAS MADE ABOUT
LOOKING AT HIRING PRACTICES.
THAT'S A BIG DEAL FOR AN
ORGANIZATION TO LOOK AT THEIR
INTERNAL PROCESSES AND SIT AND
QUESTION THEMSELVES HOW ARE WE
HIRING WHAT IS THE APPLICATION
LOOK LIKE HOW DO WE MAKE IT
MORE INCLUSIVE AND MORE OPEN.
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT MANY
ORGANIZATIONS ARE WRESTLING
WITH SO- WHILE WELL I. I HEAR
YOU ON ON THE FRUSTRATION I
ALSO SEE IT WITHIN
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE TRYING
TO DO BETTER. YOU KNOW THEY'RE
THEY'RE THEY'RE TRYING TO GET
THERE- I THINK THAT THERE'S
SEVERAL- YOU KNOW- PRIVACY
MATTERS AND THINGS OF A THINGS
THAT ARE RELATED TO HIM MORE
THE HUMAN RESOURCE FUNCTION.
THAT I THINK THAT- ATTRIBUTES
WITH WHAT YOU'RE SAYING. NUMBER
LESS BY IF I WERE TO SAY YOU
KNOW THIS POSITIVE OUTLOOK IS
THAT I SEE ORGANIZATIONS
WORKING AT THIS HARD. AND
LOOKING AT IT IN TERMS OF HOW
CAN WE SOLVE THIS HOW CAN WE BE
MORE OPEN AND MORE INCLUSIVE.
AND FOR US AT THE CHAMBER WE'RE
GOING TO RUN WITH THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS AND HELP CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OTHERS SO I
THINK- YOU KNOW WE'RE IN A
DIFFERENT TIME TODAY. AND
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY I THINK
FOR US TO REALLY HAVE- YOU KNOW
BUSINESSES STEP UP AND HELP
THEM HELP THEM. YOU KNOW DEFINE
YOU KNOW WHAT IT WHAT NEEDS
WHAT PROCESSES NEED TO BE IN
PLACE SO THAT THERE'S MORE
TRANSPARENCY AND THERE'S MORE
OPPORTUNITY AT THE END OF THE
DAY IT'S THE OUTCOMES THAT WILL
MATTER THAT'S AWESOME ABOUT
YEAH I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT I
THINK WE ARE A DIFFERENT TIME.
AND I DON'T DOUBT INTENTIONS
BUT I THINK INTENTIONS HAVE TO
BE DEALT YES AND THOSE ARE
COMES OUT THERE AND I KNOW
THAT. THEIR OTHER METRICS
INVOLVED I KNOW THAT SURE AND I
HAVE BEEN PART OF CONVERSATIONS
WHERE THERE'S DIFFERENT
PROGRAMMING ALEX USED TO ROOT
OUT. THE KIND OF THE BIAS THAT
EXISTED AND THERE'S A LOT OF
DIFFERENT APPROACHES TO IT. I
THINK WE'LL HAVE TO LOOK FIVE
YEARS AND I DON'T SEE OF THE
OUTCOMES MATCH THE INTENSITY OF
THE INTENTIONS AND A LAWSUIT
MENTIONS ON THE GENERATIONAL
WEALTH ONE OF THE GREATEST FROM
GENERATIONAL WEALTH. IS
PROPERTY ARE THERE ARE STILL A
NORMAL. ONE NORMA'S RACISM AND
BARRIERS TO PROPERTY OWNERSHIP.
AND NOW MORE THAN EVER WE'RE
SEEING- THE LAW FROM AND-
OWNERS IMPROPER THERE NOW BUT A
FOREVER. THE DOOR I PRETTY
HONOR. HAS BEEN- TO BLOCK FOUND
THAT JENNA OF THE BLOCK OUT OF
IT AND SOMETHING THAT SAYS ONE
OF THING THAT WE HAVE TO BE
INTO ABOUT THAT WE WANT TO SEE
ABOUT. RESULT. IT DID NOT AND I
KNOW IN IN MY DISTRICT- USC HAS
A BASE DATE. IT I GIVE A
PROGRAM EVERY YEAR ON ON ON
STEM PROGRAMS BRING KIDS FROM
THE COMMUNITY TO COME IN WANT
TO BE ON CAMPUS WE GET USED TO
THE CAMPUS ENVIRONMENT SOME OF
NEVER THEY WALKED AROUND USC
BUT THEY NEVER WALK THROUGH OR
IN USC. EDITOR A BLOCK AWAY AND
SO I BRING THEM ON CAMPUS AND
THEN I BRING TO THE PATERNITY
SCHOOL REGION AREA AND THEY
THEY DO ENGINEERING THINGS WITH
HIM AND THE FUN PART OF IT IS
IT IS AN ALL MATH AND IN
SCIENCE IT'S FOUGHT IT SO WE
SHOOT OFF ROCKETS RIA DO ALL
THE FUN THINGS AND I JUST
REMEMBER JUST JUST SITTING WITH
THEM. AND SAYING THAT- THERE'S.
DID YOU CAN GET A DEGREE. AND
GAMING AND I'LL LOOK UP AND GO
YOU ME LIKE- GAMES I DIDN'T YES
STIRS. EVEN GET UP
UNDERGRADUATE DEGREE AND- BUT
AT THAT TIME WHEN I FIRST
STARTED- NEW YORK UNIVERSITY
HAD DIRT AT THE BEST GATE
MEANS. AND YOU START OUT MAKING
LIKE EIGHTY NINE THOUSAND
BECAUSE OF TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR WHEN YOU
GRADUATE AND I SAID DIDN'T AND
THEN YOU SEE THESE KIDS GO OKAY
SO LET ME GET THIS STRAIGHT. I
GO TO COLLEGE FOR FOUR YEARS
SHOULD. I LEARNED EVERYTHING I
NEED TO CREATE A GAME. AND THEN
YOU PAY ME FOR THE REST OF MY
LIFE TO CREATE GAMES THAT I
PLAYED ALL THE TIME BUT I NOW
BE CREATED AND MAKE MORE THAN A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR
FOR THE REST OF MY LIFE IN THE
CITY NEXT YEAR THANKS AND I
USUALLY SAY. AND N. LESTER TO
THE MOTHERS FATHERS. THEN YOU
CAN RETIRE. AND THEY DIDN'T
TAKE CARE YOU FOR THE REST OF
YOUR LIFE AND YOU COULD SEE THE
MOTHERS SELECT A LOCATION
HEADER. FRANCE MISSTATEMENTS IN
UP. THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY OF A
LIFETIME AND- AT SCG EVERY
SCHOOL 61% OF THE
UNDERGRADUATES ARE FEMALE. AND
IN ENGINEERING. THAT'S NOT THE
CASE SO NOW WE HAVE REMEMBER
AVENUE WE GET MORE WOMEN. AN
ENGINEERING MUCH LIKE EIGHT
EIGHT YOU ONLY GET IT IF I CAN
GET MORE BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR
IN TWO ENGINEERING. AND MANY OF
THEM ARE VERY GOOD AT MATH. BUT
BETTY AT THE JUNIOR COLLEGE
IDEA IT IT CAN- MIDDLE SCHOOL
SO HOW TO GET DISTRACTED IS OUR
HORMONES ARE JUST GROWING UP TO
GET DISTRACTED. BUT IF WE CAN
CREATE THAT THAT AVENUE IN
SOUTH LOS ANGELES. A PLUS SAYS
INITIATIVE WHERE IF YOU GO. AND
BE PART A PROGRAM THROUGH FROM
MIDDLE SCHOOL THROUGH HIGH
SCHOOL DR PAVE YOUR WAY THROUGH
USC SO THERE'S A. LOT OF
OPPORTUNITIES HOW DO WE CONNECT.
HOW DO WE CAN TO A BOY A MINUTE.
INTO THAT AB. WHERE IT'S IT WAS
LIKE IT'S- AUTOMATIC SUCCESS.
PARENTS JUST NEED TO SHOW UP
ONCE A MONTH. KIDS NEED TO
COME. ON THE WEEKENDS AND YOU
GOT YOUR YOUR PARKED CAR SHOW
PROGRESS. AND- YOU GET A FOUR
YEAR SCHOLARSHIP IF YOU'RE PART
OF THAT SO HOT THERE IT BACK TO
WHAT WE'RE SAYING THERE ARE
AVENUES. BUT WE'RE WE'RE NOT
DOING A VERY EFFECTIVE JOB OF
CONNECTING THAT AND THEN WHEN
THEY GET OUT. IT'S VERY EASY TO
CONNECTING TO CHAMBER WHICH
WILL GET THEM INTO JOBS THAT
WERE KEEPING GOING FOR THE REST
OF YOUR LIFE. AT AND I THINK
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT AN AGE
RANGE THAT MIDDLE SCHOOL AGE
RANGE. IS KEY IT THAT
INVESTMENT OF ANY KIND THAT CAN
BE MADE WITH IN THAT MIDDLE
SCHOOL. YEARS I THINK YOU KNOW
JUST FOR MY EXPERIENCE IS A
MOTHER. THAT THAT'S WHERE YOU
KNOW THEY REALLY FORM THAT
FOUNDATION THAT WILL CARRY THEM
THROUGH HIGH SCHOOL THAT WILL
PREPARE THEM FOR A COLLEGE
CAREER LIKE AN INVERTER B. SO-
YOU KNOW I'VE FOUGHT THIS
COMMITTEE FOR LOOKING AT. THE
BOYS BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE THEY
NEED TO BE INSPIRED AT THAT
TIME FRAME. GOOD EXCUSE ME- BUT
THIS WAS WALLACE EPILEPSY COULD
NOT. FIELD LEADERS YES IT IS.
YOU MAY BEGIN HERE. YEAH I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE BRIEF COMMENTS
AROUND- I AGREE WITH THIS OUR
UP MY FELLOW PANELISTS THE L.
UP DE LA CHAMBER THAT ON THIS
IMPORTANT TO BUILD THESE PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS IN MIDDLE
SCHOOL IS QUITE IMPORTANT
UPDATE INFLECTION POINT IN
ONE'S CAREER WHAT ALSO ARGUED
THAT IMPORTANT PARTS PRESENTS
IMPORTANT TO ENSURE THAT THE
PARENTS OF THOSE MIDDLE
SCHOOLERS ARE. ACTUALLY CIRCLE
BACK TO. YOU KNOW THE FOLKS IN
ON ACTS TO EMPLOYMENT. ACTUALLY
CAREER PATH SALARY ACADEMIC.
CAREER AND ECONOMIC MOBILITY IS
A TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY FOR
CORPORATE AMERICA LEAN AND MORE
ARE MOVING IN BEYOND JUST
LOOKING AT THESE- STATISTICS
OUTCOMES PROPOSITIONAL
INDICATED THAT RELATES TO
DIVERSITY AND REALLY LOOKING AT
POLICIES PRACTICES IN PEOPLE
MANAGEMENT STRATEGIES THAT
CREATE. AN ANTI RACIST
ENVIRONMENT- AND I STAND BEFORE
YOU I'M NOT FOR YOU BUT
BIRCHLEY- TO PRESENT- A
PERSPECTIVE THAT CORPORATE
CITIZENSHIP- NEEDS TO ADOPT A
ANTI RACISM WHEN I SAY THAT- WE
LOOK AT ONE OF THE MOST RACES
SYSTEMS IN OUR NATION IS OUR
CON. AND THAT IS AT SEVEN FIVE
BY THE WEALTH AND INCOME
INEQUALITY GAP WHERE AFRICAN
AMERICAN MEN ARE MAKING SEVENTY
CENTS ON THE DOLLAR FOR EVERY
WHAT ONE DOLLAR WHITE MAN MAKES
ON THE FACT THAT CORPORATE
AMERICA WAS A HUNDRED AND 75%
OF THE LABOR MARKET. GIVE THEM
THE POWER TO SHIFT- THE
SYSTEMIC DRIVERS THAT BECAUSE
THESE THIS GAP BETWEEN WEALTHY
INCOME- EXACERBATE NAMELY IN
THE AREAS OF EDUCATION AND
ALIGNED WITH THE FUTURE OF WORK
WE'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT THAT I
THINK THIS TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY TO REIMAGINE CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION THROUGH
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP.
pOF OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES OR
THROUGH PARTNERSHIPS LIKE WITH
OUR ORGANIZATION LEADERS UP AND
GOOGLE DOT ORG THAT IS SCALING
CAREER CERTIFICATES THAT ARE
RECOGNIZED BY EMPLOYERS THAT
ARE CONNECTING INDIVIDUALS TO
WAGES THAT START OF ABOUT SIXTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR WE
NEED MORE DEMAND DRIVEN
EMPLOYER THEIR CAREER AND
TECHNICAL EDUCATION DIGITALLY-
AS WELL AS A BRICK AND MORTAR.
THE SECOND AREAS IN- EMPLOYMENT
AND- PROMOTION OR CAREER
PATHWAYS WE NEED TO REIMAGINE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS THAT
WORK FOR EMPLOYERS NOT BOGGED
DOWN IN BUREAUCRACY IT BEING
RECOGNIZED VERY EARLY ORDER
BUILT A PARTNERSHIP BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY- ONE THAT IS
ALIGNED WITH THE FUTURE OF WORK
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY THE
COMPETENCY AND SKILLS THAT
EMPLOYERS NEEDS. WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO THROUGH A PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE SELL PRICE- CENTER FOR
SOCIAL INNOVATION YOU KNOW OR-
CAL. BUT THEY WOULD BE SIGNED
WITH EMPLOYERS FETA YOU.
GRANGER UP AND GO. THE NUMBER
OF CAREER PATHWAY THAT WE HAVE
THE- OUT LAND FOLKS BOB A
MINUTE- AVERAGING WAY JUST
ABOUT EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR. I'M LAST BUT NOT LEAST
WE'RE LOOKING AT COMPENSATION
AND BENEFITS AS ANOTHER DRIVER
THAT EMPLOYERS HAVE THE ABILITY
TO ACTUALLY- PULL A STRATEGIC
LEVEL TO CLOSE THE GAP.
SPECIFICALLY AS WE TALKED ABOUT
WAS ME THE COLOR THROUGHOUT
THIS ENTIRE AFTERNOON FROM THE
TRAUMA INFORMED BY. PILOTS TO-
BEHAVIOR HEALTH SERVICES ALL OF
THIS IS CONNECTED TO ECONOMIC
STABILITY OR AT. OUTCOME BUTTON
I CAN IN. I WILL WE ALL- WE
LOOK AT THE SOCIAL SERVICE
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS ARE OFFERED
TO YOU THAT WE NEED TO PARTNER
WITH. THE CORPORATE ABOUT
CORPORATE AMERICA PRIVATE
SECTOR TO TRANSFORM THE STATION
THAT- PROGRAMS INTO OPPORTUNITY
TRAMPOLINE PROGRAMS ONES THAT
COUNTS IN CATALYZE WAS A MINUTE
COLOR FURTHER INTO THE WEALTH.
ACCUMULATED ACROSS THE WEALTH
ACCUMULATION SPECTER. THINGS
LIKE PROVIDING SUBSIDIES AROUND
HOUSING CHILDCARE
TRANSPORTATION ARE CORRECT BUT
ALSO WHERE ARE THE
OPPORTUNITIES TO PARTNER WITH
THE UP WITH THE PUBLIC SECTOR
TO RAISE THE THRESHOLD FOR BOYS
A MINUTE COLOR RALPH AREAS OF
OPPORTUNITY THAT WILL HELP THE
BILL WELL. I FIRST TIME HOME
OWNERSHIP PROGRAMS SO MANY
TIMES WE START WORKING THE
START TO LIVE UP START MAKING A
DECENT WAGE LOSS AND DECENT WE
LOOK AT THE FIGHT FOR FIFTEEN
DOLLARS AN HOUR FIFTEEN DOLLARS
AN HOUR SIXTEEN SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS A WEEK. TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED DOLLARS A. MONTH GROSS
NOT NET. AVERAGE A RARE. A CAL.
TWELVE FORTY DOLLARS WILL YOU
THINK ABOUT THAT WHEN THE
CLIENT IS A LIVING OFF A
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER MONTH. YOU
CAN DO THAT SO WE THINK ABOUT
THINGS LIKE UNIVERSAL- IT
INCOME. AND OTHER OPPORTUNITIES
LET'S ALSO PUBLIC WELL GET THE
PRIVATE SECTOR MORE INVOLVED
INTO. UP STRATEGIES WITH THE
PUBLIC SECTOR THAT ACTUALLY
HELPS RAISE THE QUALITY OF LIFE
IN THE AFFORDABILITY AND
QUALITY OF LIFE. THESE ARE
AREAS THAT CORPORATE AMERICA
SHOULD LEAN INTO. IF THEY ARE
MOVING BEYOND STATEMENTS AROUND
RACIAL JUSTICE IN LOOKING AT
PROBLEMS OF RACIAL INEQUITY.
ACTUALLY ADVANCING AN ANTI
RACIST PERSPECTIVE. ARGUABLY
ARE COUNTING IS BEEN THERE IT
HAS BEEN RACES SINCE IT'S TO
SIGN. UP HOWEVER COMMA GIVEN
THE INFLUX OF CORPORATE
CORPORATIONS. AND-
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS OUR STATE
ARE NOW ANSWER JEFF IS
IMPORTANT FOR US TO NOW HOLD
THEM ACCOUNTABLE IN HELP TO
OPERATIONALIZE THE STRATEGIES
BEYOND PROGRAMS- THAT INTERVENE
WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
WORKING WITH CORPORATIONS. TO
GENERATE THE TOP BOX
OPPORTUNITIES NECESSARY. THANK
YOU I'M GLAD WE FINALLY GOT YOU
AND- I WHERE ABOUT FIFTEEN
MINUTES PAST OUR OUR TIME AT
THREE THIRTY- UNLESS THERE ANY
FINAL COMMENTS FROM. ANY OF THE
MEMBERS THAT ARE LEFT MR
LACKEY. JUST REAL BRIEFLY I. I
THINK SOME SOME VERY VALID
POINTS HAVE BEEN MADE- THROUGH
THE REMARKS OF- PANELIST AND
SPEAKERS HERE TODAY. I THINK
THAT- ONE OF THE GREAT
CHALLENGES THAT WE- FACE AS A
SOCIETY IS GETTING AND ONE OF
THE GREAT BARRIERS- THAT WE
FACE IS GETTING OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE ESPECIALLY. BOYS AND MEN
OF COLOR TO BELIEVE IN-THEMSELVES. AND I THINK THE WAY
WE DO THAT IS WHICH WAS
OUTLINED IN SOME OF THE- OTHER
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMMING IS TO
BUILD. MENTORSHIP AND THE SENSE
OF FAMILY PEOPLE THEY TRUST.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHO THEY RESPOND
TO. AND- I THINK THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF. CIRCUMSTANCES THAT OF-
DOES ALLOW PEOPLE TO TRUST THE
RIGHT PEOPLE. AND I THINK THAT
THAT'S LED TO A VERY-
DISCOURAGING CENTER
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WE'RE-
REALIZING NOW AND I THINK THAT
WE'RE ALL. TRYING TO PARTNER
AND I THINK THAT- AS WE
ENCOURAGE OUR YOUNG MEN AND-
OUR BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR TO-
TO EMBRACE OPPORTUNITY WE HAVE
TO ALSO YOU KNOW ENHANCE
OPPORTUNITIES BUT ONCE THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES COME. YOU HAVE TO
REACT YOU HAVE TO REACT IN A
POSITIVE MANNER AND WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE WE'RE DOING THAT AND
COURAGE IN. OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
TO- TAKE THESE OPPORTUNITIES
BECAUSE THEIR TRUST LEVELS
LOWER. AND THEY'VE HAD A LOT OF
DISCOURAGE MOOD THEY'VE HAD A
LOT OF THE- NEGATIVE
EXPERIENCES AND TO GET. PEOPLE
TO REFOCUS THEIR TRUST IT'S
DIFFICULT AND SO I THINK THAT'S
WHERE OUR FOCUS NEEDS TO BE IN
ON THE COURAGE BY ALL THE
ORGANIZATIONS AND ALL THE
PEOPLE WHO UNDERSTAND WHAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE BECAUSE WHEN
IT'S ALL SAID AND DONE THE TRUE
MEASURE OF SUCCESS OUR
OUTCOMES. AND IF WE'RE NOT
GETTING OUTCOMES WERE NOT-
MOVING WHERE WE NEED TO GO SO
I'M VERY HOPEFUL AND- I THANK
EVERYBODY FOR THEIR TIME TODAY.
THANK YOU MR LACKEY AND WITH
THAT I WILL RETURN TO SELECT
COMMITTEE OF BOYS MINUTE COLOR
INFORMATIONAL HEARING.